ou les title Tuesday
chase.com/evenscool tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroulent en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
tournoi de Blitz après la brillante
victoire de Maxime va chier Lagrave dans
le rapide il a été impérial 7 sur 9 1.5
victoires 4 nulles 0 défaite
extraordinaire en contrôle total à
partir du deuxième jour premier jour un
petit peu plus
hésitant mais quand même un beau score
de 2 sur 3 et après il a déroulé il a
pris la confiance il a déroulé il a été
incroyable on a quasi on s'est quasi pas
inquiété enfin les jours 2 et 3 donc
c'était c'était formidable ce qui nous a
fait
et voilà maintenant on va suivre
évidemment le
[Musique]
tournoi de Blitz je cherche la bonne
scène hop là celle-là voilà où on a où
on voit rien pour l'instant mais ce
qu'on va faire pour le Blitz si vous
êtes d'accord c'est quand on va se
mettre comme ça je suis dans le public
et on voit l'échiquier regardez hop là
c'est comme vous voulez ou alors on peut
suivre avec
alors attendez ça c'est pas mal aussi
ouais comme vu évidemment faut changer
Maxime on va suivre évidemment je vais
pas vous dire qu'on va suivre vite toute
la journée on va suivre évidemment
mvl toute la journée et bon ben voilà ça
va être beau
quel est le format c'est très simple on
reprend les 10 mêmes joueurs et on
recommence qu'est-ce qui se passe il y a
9 rondes je m'installe un peu mieux
pas terrible siège ouais meilleur vu
celle-ci peut-être peut-être on va voter
on va voter
et
donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait on joue qu'on
est neuf autres joueurs une fois avec
les Blancs une fois avec les Noirs donc
toute la journée vous allez voir Maxime
affronter les 9 autres joueurs et le
lendemain c'est à dire demain 11h30 même
heure même place et bien nous allons
voir les matchs retour celui qui marque
le plus de points sur les 18 parties et
déclarer vainqueur le deuxième est
déclaré deuxième voilà comment ça va se
passer
on a évidemment quand il est comme ça on
rappelle demain c'est 10h30 au début
mais c'est sûr
c'est sûr ça j'étais pas sûr
j'étais pas sûr
on m'a dit on m'a dit 11h30 moi ou alors
je me suis je me suis trompé bon je vais
vérifier ça à la pause mais en tout cas
c'est pas possible ça soit 10h30 là pour
le coup
je vais demander
la cadence la cadence et oui j'ai oublié
la cadence bienvenue
Bienvenue
la cadence c'est du on n'a pas de place
en VIP on est derrière et on voit que ça
commence à aller pendules sont mal sans
malmise mais on va on va regarder on va
regarder d'abord comme ça les pendules
sont malmises je vais vous les mettre
dans le
bon ordre donc Sacha great chou qui
commence déjà à réfléchir
et
Maxime donc qui nous surprend avec son
grand vidame
voilà il y a un léger décalage par
rapport au cou ça va être ennuyeux ce
truc
mais on voit quelque chose de très
solide une structure carsbah de la part
de Maxime
et
contre grichu qui a une grosse
expérience qui a été trois fois champion
du monde se rappelle que Maxime on aura
le temps de discuter entre les parties
maxime a été champion du monde 2021 mai
on va regarder tout de suite la partie
donc structure
C6 des 5 contre le pion e3d4 qui avait
lieu 8 un petit coup inventé par Jordan
van forest pour le match de championnat
du monde face à Yann les pommyashi était
dans l'équipe de Magnus et Magnus lance
ensuite utilisé on voit deux joueurs qui
joue très vite ça va être un peu la
panique évidemment parce que
c'est du Blitz donc
on va voir ce que ça donne mais Maxime
très bien préparés c'est du 3 plus 2
3 + 2
3 + 2 la cadence clairement
moi je crois que c'est tous les jours à
la même heure mais on va regarder on va
regarder tout ça et gritchou comme
d'habitude qui réfléchitours en général
on fait fouet F8 on fait cavalier F5
voilà c'est jouer certainement cavalier
F5 qui va arriver au cahier des 7
cavaliers F6 qui va arriver aussi fou F4
ça prépare F3 suivi de 4 ça va être très
intéressant 3 + 2 c'est extrêmement
rapide pour du Blitz
qui commence à l'habitude prend de
l'avance au temps comme dans les rapides
et on va voir tout ça F3 ouais cavalier
F6 on empêche 4 il fait quel G3 il en
remet une couche pour jouer ce fameux E3
E4 et maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec les noirs et bien je n'en sais rien
je n'en sais rien voir la réponse
parfois on fait des B5 B4 bizarrement ou
des B5 à essai 4 ça va très vite de 30
contre 2 10 pour gretchu quelque chose
qui prend toujours un peu plus de temps
dans les débuts voilà maxime a priori il
va pas se lever pendant les Blitz
normalement il reste il reste assis
on va voir on va voir ce que ça donne
et Maxime qui réfléchit première pause
pour lui dans ce Blitz et il faut faire
attention comment on empêche le 4
maintenant c'est la question que se pose
Maxime
il
a vraiment la question et un quatre
quatre qui peut arriver
4 qui va arriver je crois E4 oh d'abord
petit coup de préparation il dit il dit
quelque chose je le fais quand je veux
alors peut-être que c'est 4 ici
peut-être qu'il C4 c'est le coup faut
prendre puis on prend c'est pas grave on
a la paire de fond ensuite on fait des
cinq B4 c'est ça les idées
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire Maxime il prend
beaucoup de temps il est pas habitué à
ce genre de structure carsbad donc faut
faire attention au bled de de pas trop
jouer faut jouer des choses sur
lesquelles on est à l'aise en général
mais bon on s'inquiète pas pour Maxime
il va jouer 4 à mon avis dois-je jouer
qui a été cadre c'est structure c'est
souvent le coup
menace qui prend B2 force à prendre en
ces quatre
on va voir on va voir ce que fait Maxime
et non il joueait 5 oh là là j'ai 5 la
jauge je n'aime pas du tout et moi non
plus le commentateur inquiet aussi ouh
là là j'ai 5 x 5 va arriver il va faire
quel est 17 Maxime et ramasser le fou
mais bon ça paraît très très optimiste
et C4 ah il combine G5
ok ok mais il faut prendre les cavaliers
E4 on s'est quand même affaibli
énormément le roi
ça me plaît pas tout ça ah j'aurais pas
joué j'ai 5 je vous le dis mais bon
effectivement Maxime un expert en blitz
évidemment
contre gris Tchouk trois fois champion
du monde donc c'est la partie c'est une
grosse partie c'est pas une partie pour
du beurre ça joue fort vous prend on va
être joué suite cavalier 4 à mon avis ou
alors le 4 peut-être je sais pas ce
qu'il va faire il prend en C4 ça c'est
sûr et joue F4 ah ça donne F4 F4 menace
pion prend attention aux cavaliers
peut-être que j'ai 4 mais alors que j'ai
4 F5 peut-être ouh là là ouh là là ça
craint ça craint pour Maxime là
cette première ronde mais attention il
est très fort pour en avoir subi la
meilleure expérience c'est pas le tout
d'être gagnant contre Maxime il faut
gagner les parties et je peux vous dire
que c'est pas évident Fuger 7 jouer il
est complètement foutu d'après la jauge
mais c'est du Blitz on s'en moque enfin
on s'en moque non on préfère être bien
mais bon c'est pas encore très très
grave peut-être cavalier 4 va arriver et
après peut-être qu'il décide ouh là ça
me plaît pas du tout sur case noire tout
ça mais attention qui réfléchit prends
ton temps Sacha prends ton temps
prends ton temps surtout faut peser le
pour et le contre dans la vie
il faut réfléchir
il prend G5 d'abord et que j'ai quatre
joints tempo ça c'est typique Maxime ça
y est le cavalier qui s'infiltre c'est
pas bon du tout d'après la jauge mais on
a mis la machine arnaque en route vous
prendrez ces trois projets 7
et notre ami qui ne prend pas de RTT si
vous entendez le bruit je suis vraiment
désolé je vais fermer la porte la
fenêtre pardon je croyais qu'il avait
pris des vacances il n'a pas pris
puis on prend H6
ah ça fait un tour de moi ouh là c'est
dur c'est chaud parce que ça va venir
sur case noir mais attention damage
Catherine menace terrible
damascade grosse menace pour les pour
les Noirs ici d'un match 4 comment on va
faire comment on va faire pour empêcher
la Mach4 de la part de gretchup d'un F3
et oui protège ici sur damage 4 il aura
H3 damage 4 jouets quand même H3 et dame
prend H6 va être joué certainement pour
toucher trois je suppose que Maxime va
faire ça
mais il est tellement fort pour arnaquer
ce genre de partie d'un prince 6 joué
attaque le pion 3 tout peut se passer
encore même si ça a l'air quand même
c'est du solide vous voyez l'école
classique de gris de chocolat
on la reconnaît même en blitz puis en
plus pour les blancs le roi faible c'est
moins bon c'est moins bien pour les
Noirs c'est une évidence après après
c'est du bled attention au roi j'ai une
énorme menace pour gagner la pièce donc
faut s'organiser là sur ce truc là ouh
là ça va être dur ça va être dur en 10
secondes 10 secondes
si notre ami c'est toujours la même
planche oui c'est notre ami bosse demain
je vais me plaindre je sais pas à qui
j'écris mais je là c'est pas possible le
week-end on n'a pas le droit de
travailler le week-end sauf si on
commandait partie d'échec et on a le
droit donc j'ai 8 ok 3 G1 c'est pas
certainement non d'un F4 clou ah c'est
embêtant tout ça voilà tourgé 8 il veut
RA évidemment ramener la tour mais des
cinq et oui ou toi si ça s'est bien joué
ou la Tour Eiffel 6 c'est l'embrouille
qui commence allez ou cavalier F5 ça
s'est bien joué comment on fait avec ce
cavalier il fait tourgé 8 il protège roi
géant a l'air d'être décisif
je crois que j'ai un suivi depuis on
prend mais attention tour H6 devrait
arriver et c'est ton jamais c'est ton
jamais mais c'est compliqué les joueurs
jouent sur un crémant
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire gretchou qui
joue à géant tourage 6
et tour E4 il veut prendre G4 à puis on
prend des 5 et prendre MD8 s'ajoute très
vite
il va donner ça à la tour la tour la
tour hyper une pièce Maxime il perd une
pièce et abandon abandon de Maxime
Vacher la grande va voir s'il y a une
autre partie en cours est-ce qu'il y a
une autre partie en cours oui entre midi
et Krishna entre vieditaire et Krishna
comment ça se passe on va aller voir on
va essayer de regarder les fins des
parties mais franchement
ça va être compliqué
de regarder tout ça qu'est-ce qui se
passe là sur les parties
et
visiter à peut-être qu'est-ce qu'il y a
comme partie intéressante
on va essayer d'aller voir notre ami
Google
sont essaie de trouver
et vous cacher
on va essayer de tourner l'échiquier
pour voir du côté
noir abdosa torov qui est complètement
foutu mais attention ils sont très fort
ambits c'est ces jeunes gens
et Roy F3 et recul il a un pion de plus
pour les blancs
et attention échec
encore un échec
et voyez sur casse blanche on est bien
on a le bon tandem cavalier contre dame
fou
ça a l'air foutu quand même pour Abdou
clairement
et voyez il joue il hésite pas à
s'infiltrer avec son roi waouh il a pas
peur mais c'est vrai que c'est que
finalement il se passe pas grand chose
sur un échec ici on reviendrait là
et roi G6 et en dominé avec le roi il y
a pas d'échec ouh là là d'un meuf 5
celui de dame 6 peut-être on pousse le
pion
on amène le cavalier voilà c'est pas mal
joué ou il donne le pion et c'est Mato
prochain c'est fini
c'est fini
et abandon de
Nandy bec Abdou Sator Rohff le champion
du monde
2021 pas de Blitz mais de
rapide et c'est fini pour cette pour
cette ronde ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on va tout de suite faire
un petit point résultat parce que ça va
très vite résultat donc Prague abattu
avec Easy ah non non pardon résultat
Blitz je dis n'importe quoi regardez je
l'ai là la ronde 1
kit Maxime avant la vue dure dur dur dur
pour
Krishna nul Google
a gagné
face à Raja BOV alors c'est la première
onde du bled rien de grave clairement
clairement on va voir maintenant
la ronde 2 contre qui va jouer Maxime
Maxime va jouer Prague avec les Blancs
je ne sais pas exactement quand c'est
que ça reprend donc on va regarder tout
ça
avec
curiosité pour savoir
quand est-ce qu'il joue la prochaine
alors ce qu'on va regarder c'est comme
ça
on va faire ça on va se mettre sur la
partie de Maxime du côté blanc
et
et on va voir dans combien de temps ça
reprend c'est toutes les 20 minutes je
crois c'est pas impossible
on a maximum on va se mettre bien donc
on va mettre de score malheureusement
femelle de score aussi quand mvl est
aussi dans le dur bon ben zéro sur il y
a pas de il y a pas de désastre c'est un
mauvais début ça c'est certain
mais
bon il peut il peut revenir il a joué
une grosse partie
notre ami notre ami Sacha greatchouk
on va voir
on rappelle évidemment au niveau du
classement ouf je change de placement
d'accord
le classement mène on va faire ça
je pense que ça devrait marcher j'ai pas
pensé à ça qu'il fallait changer et
voilà on voit trois joueurs à un point
trois joueurs à 0 bon c'est la première
ronde donc il se passe pas grand chose
on rappelle c'est du 3 plus 2
ce qu'on va aller voir
tout ensemble
c'est à quelle heure ça commence demain
parce que vous m'avez mis le doute
ah ça c'est pas mal comme
faudrait le jeu
8 jours 1 contrôle de temps ah j'ai pas
changé le contrôle de temps
alors
faire et oui contrôle de temps ce qu'on
va faire c'est que je vais changer
et je suis de retour
donc on va en direct Maxime qu'elle est
blanche on va aller voir je suis pas
préparé du tout on adore
ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va aller
là et on va regarder le
ensemble on va regarder ce qui est drôle
ce qu'on m'a raconté des histoires ou
pas
programme programme
ah ouais il y a un beau programme 8
et le 9 ça joue à donc le 8 ça joue à
11h30 exactement
et demain c'est à 10h30 et bien voilà
donc demain une heure plus tôt
il faut changer il faut changer
l'horaire je crois que Nathan avait mis
ou alors je c'est moi c'est moi qui
craque peut-être donc demain c'est pas
la même heure c'est une heure plus tôt
et
on va regarder tout ça
donc on aura un petit décalage et oui
c'est souvent comme ça pour la remise
des prix
on va peut-être regarder on va essayer
de voir les caméras ce qui se passe sur
les caméras il se passe rien du tout et
joueurs qui sont pas là mais clairement
ça reprend toutes les 20 minutes donc ça
doit être un peu plus rapide qu'hier
on devrait finir un peu plus tôt mais
ça va être le temps
ça c'est sûr ouais bravo à Paul la
cagole
non oui
qui avait la bonne
la bonne rêve sur l'horaire
effectivement malagasi 56 salut à toi
salut à tous il y a un classement cumulé
Blitz rapide non pas du tout je raconte
n'importe quoi il y a pas de classement
cumulé c'est un classement c'est fini le
rapide c'est gagné c'est dommage
d'ailleurs pour Maxime parce que il
aurait pu tout gagner beaucoup plus
facilement
mais clairement
il y a deux tournois distincts et donc
un tournoi de partir rapide et un
tournoi de Blitz
donc on va suivre tout ça et
malheureusement Maxime repart à zéro
ça fait ça fait que commencer
et on le voit le score de Maxime on le
voit pas
on le voit pas parce que il faut passer
là-dessus
le score de Maxi mais ici mais je crois
que je vais me mettre comme ça
honnêtement on va reprendre la place
faut qu'on reprenne la place vip là
c'est pas possible
ça ne va pas du tout
il y a pas trop là peut-être allez
devant le petit garçon à reprendre cette
place vip
quand on est en VIP
on va voir il joue le jeune Prague
et salut à tous donc évidemment il y
aura toujours des petites pauses entre
les parties donc n'hésitez pas à poser
vos questions à discuter
ce que vous voulez évidemment plutôt
d'échec
voilà au revoir
il y a pas de rapport entre le Blitz et
rapide il y a aucun rapport c'est juste
que c'est le même tournoi avec les mêmes
joueurs mais ces deux tournois
complètement distincts ils ont décidé de
pas faire un combiné bon c'est leur
choix je crois que la première année il
y avait eu un combiné en mode grandes
chaise tour c'est peut-être aussi pour
différencier du Grand chest tour
clairement ils ont envie certainement de
faire un autre format les compteur sur à
zéro et le score de mvl est
malheureusement de 0 grosse partie de
greachuka clairement il a pas fait
beaucoup d'erreurs
ouais l'angle des caméras ne soit pas
plus surélevé je suis d'accord
je suis d'accord je suis d'accord que
l'angle des caméras devrait être devrait
être plus élevé
complètement mais bon
c'est comme ça c'est déjà pas mal on a
des belles caméras donc on est content
ouais
qui est un format particulier
après je sais pas si j'ai l'impression
que préférer le format le format
grandgestu où il y a rapide et Blitz
cumulé
mais en vrai c'est peut-être parce que
je suis plus habitué je sais pas
je sais pas Stéphane Cogat qui demande
combien a gagné un bel a remporter en
rapide je sais qu'il y a 41000 dollars
de prix
au total mais je pense qu'ils ont des
ils ont des cachets
ils ont des starting fille comme on dit
ah ouais
ok je peux mettre sur les escaliers ça
c'est pas mal
ah ouais bonne idée tiens
un peu plus grand allez on est sur les
escaliers
voilà
comme ça on voit bien on est assis on a
mis une chaise au milieu des escalier on
est bien là alors on va essayer de voir
maintenant
ah non du coup du coup là on a
je suis arbitre de chaise
on va se mettre au milieu des escaliers
on va se mettre là avec un Maxime va se
ou la maxime quand il va se pencher
ça va être compliqué alors on a Maxime
avec les Blancs contre pragamanda le
jeune joueur
et bien qui a fait une formidable en
Coupe du Monde on le répète à jamais
assez
mais
bon ça reste du Blitz sans avoir si
Maxime va se remettre attention et
Maxime il peut faire des séries assez
immenses on va se mettre là plutôt
voilà pour que vous puissiez me voir là
il y a pas oh la chaise
ou la chaise ou la chaise je la prends
un chaise VIP ça fait un petit peu
arbitre arbitre de chaises peut
quasiment appuyer sur la pendule allez
on va voir est-ce qu'il va jouer aussi
Maxime qui a pas joué oh là les pendule
merci
parce que c'est en mettant à chaque fois
et Maxime qui clairement à pas jouer son
répertoire ou la des catalanes ouh là là
quand même parce que franchement si je
joue pas son répertoire ça peut être
plus compliqué
on n'a pas les bons réflexes en blitz
enfin on a voilà si on n'est pas habitué
on peut ne pas avoir les bons réflexes
qui est ici ce qui attaquent le pion
directement et pra qui joue une petite
ligne pour surprendre mvl je crois que
le coup ici c'est le 3 il joue qu'avf3
il y a E3 aussi et l'attention c'est
reprendre la dame il y a eu le cas je
crois qu'il arrive mais on reprend du
cavalier
normalement pas sûr
et il reprend du cavalier mais il
réfléchit déjà dès le début des 6 on va
faire le 5 et on va challenger ce centre
blanc pra qui joue très très vite qui a
l'air de connaître clairement
et petit rock
on va jouer E4 normalement on essaie de
prendre de l'espace
le fera t-il il est déjà mal au temps
Maxime 40 secondes de moins surpris
surpris par le choix d'ouverture de
Prague attention attention à pas se
mettre mal au temps à chaque partie
ça peut ça peut jouer Maxime qui joue
normalement tellement vite et tellement
bien en blitz il a l'air un peu plus
lent là il joue il fait des
tentes des choses tenter des choses en
plus c'est toujours compliqué
et ça y est il ferme le jeu et le
cavalier revient en B8 il va venir voilà
à 5 allez à 6 et on va revenir par là on
va revenir par là le cavalier va venir
ici
mais les Noirs ont aucun problème à mon
avis d'un genre de position fou de cette
C6 et tout va bien pour les noirs
c'est très compliqué d'organiser F4
c'est ce qu'on a envie d'organiser avec
les blancs mais c'est pas facile du tout
et joue cahier des sets ok ça c'est un
peu étonnant pour jouer qui est ces 5
tours vous voyez bien il veut faire F4
alors il peut pas le faire tout de suite
probablement il y a que les 4 qui arrive
non il prend d'abord ses 5
et peut-être F4 ou pas
F4 jouer
et peut-être F5 maintenant pour prendre
l'aile roi
d'assautant il veut il veut continuer à
mettre la pression mais bon ça fait pas
trop la pression les Noirs vont jouer
ces six ou B5 ils vont jouer à une dame
les noirs
pas du tout ici
mais sans quel coup à mon avis
cette C6 d'abord aussi c'est 6 pour
challenger un petit peu ce centre et à
mon avis réfléchit entre ces deux
options ou alors encore un coup de
préparation on va voir
les cinq jouets par Prague très très
logique on réagit à la dame
et attention est-ce qu'on laisse faire
B4 est-ce qu'on laisse faire puis on
prend ces quatre c'est pas sûr c'est pas
sûr du tout
B3 et B4 maintenant à 4 va arriver
ensuite ah là là c'est pas terrible du
tout ça pour Maxime malheureusement
il s'agirait de pas commencer avec deux
bulles
c'est quand même un peu compliqué là
à 4
et on a tout le jeu F5 qu'on fait F6
mais là c'est très lent c'est très lent
on a on a déjà tout le jeu tour à deux
va arriver évidemment où tour à trois un
des deux tour à 3 pour menacer x 4 aussi
il semble pas mal tu auras deux jouets
on va mettre le la petite sœur la petite
sœur à 8 et ensuite on va essayer
simplement de doubler sur la seconde
c'est pas bon du tout
pour un tour à 8 mais on n'a jamais de
jeu là-bas il y a pas assez de pièces
pour mater j'ai 5 et alors qu'est-ce
qu'on fait après j'ai 5 on fait rien les
noirs sont très très bien ici
aucun problème on fait un coup de H6 si
on est de naturel inquiet mais il est
pas programmer
peut-être qu'il valait être est-ce qu'il
est naturelle un qui est notre ami
Prague et pas du tout il s'en moque il
veut faire tour ces trois et encaisser
le pion il rigole pas
et il a bien raison il a bien raison de
pas rigoler et c'est Maxime qui engueule
pas avec une minute de moins et une
poubelle intersidérale mais alors
peut-être il essaie de faire du contre
jeu il y a tout reprend des deux là et
qu'il prend V3 oh là là tactique la
tactique ratée
ou pas
tu reprends des oeufs à me prendre des
deux caille prend B3 on apprend à
récupérer la tour ce pion là est-ce
qu'on réussir à le protéger le prépare
pour être sûr de mettre quelque chose
derrière
ah oui protège le pion V3 bien joué de
la part de Maxime tour C3 mais attention
ça vient dans tous les sens là c'est
l'enfer et la dame pourrait se joindre à
l'assaut par B6
c'est un enfer peut-être qu'il y a des
trois cavaliers F4 oh là là pour Maxime
là c'est très dur c'est très dur Maxime
dans très dur
contre Prague on va voir une 45 contre
une minute
ça peut arriver un des mauvais début de
tournoi mais ensuite s'il met la machine
la machine en route ça peut faire très
mal aussi il peut il peut faire des
séries de de victoire
assez épatante de mb8 je vous l'avais
dit on va jouer sur casse noire qui est
des trois va arriver à un moment ou à un
autre ça va être très très compliqué
pour mvl dans cette situation
et Maxime qui réfléchit elle est pas
facile à jouer cette position
regardez-moi ça ouh là là ça va pas du
tout
mais en même temps j'ai pas de bons
conseils à lui donner là dans cette dans
cette poubelle il faut appeler les
choses par leur nom ça ne va pas du tout
et c'est très dur à jouer en plus faut
être en permanence il faut garder le roi
alors j'ai 5 ok ça c'est un coup de
Blitz pour essayer de se faire un peu de
contre-jour on peut pas lui en vouloir
même si très probablement c'est vrai que
ça ça fait bien encore un peu plus sa
position
alors j'ai 5 peut-être on fait le coup
du retour là pour poser une question
essayer de devenir avec la dame de
s'infiltrer ou pas en Peugeot recette
aussi cette fève cet espace là et fais
dame D8 il pose une question sur le
pionger dame G2 ou la cahier des trois
cavaliers F4 qui va arriver je vous en
avais parlé de cette idée le cavalier F4
va être un monstre autour du roi du roi
blanc là ça va pas aller du tout
comment on fait
dans la 12 secondes pour Maxime qui aime
pas du tout qui normalement un flot très
très fluide en emblite mais là c'est pas
du tout son style de position il essaye
d'improviser un petit peu mais là ça ne
prend pas du tout c'est un désastre
peut-être même tourage 3 pour encaisser
le pion et forcer les blancs à faire
quelque chose pour ces deux a l'air pas
mal aussi attaque un petit peu tout de
la famille
un choix très plaisant pour Prague c'est
notre finalement seul espoir
dans ces deux attaquent le roi attaque
le cavalier pardon le roi
qui vient protéger
tant bien que mal peut-être le roi va
venir ici ensuite bon pour l'instant ça
tient ça gagne pas mais ça tient 8
secondes simplement pour Maxime contre
47 et revient Prague il a tout son temps
évidemment Maxime qui est d'accord pour
la nul mais il veut améliorer sa
position en jouant roi des 1 évidemment
qu'une nul est un bon résultat un
tournage 3 attaque le pion je vous avais
parlé
puis on pourrait faire dame prend ça
laisse tour à 8 mais c'est pas très
grave que le F3 est une gaffe fois 5 je
pense clos les débat X5 terrible clouage
ça va pas du tout
ok il prend le 2 il faut H5 il fait
qu'elle prend un deux et fois H5 et oui
tour à 8 ça sera un seul échec sur un
roi de 7 et ça sera terminé au roi F7
c'est la même chose et le cavalier est
perdu
pardon qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
non il joue ton assiette Maxime
faut prendre F3 il a une pièce de moins
il a joué avec une seconde et jouera des
deux il est pas du tout habitué à jouer
avec aussi peu de temps damage 6 MG5
mille et une pièce de moins un Maxime va
chez Lagrave dame prend j'ai 5 va
arriver ou alors tout reprend jusqu'à
dame prend G5 c'est plus simple et vous
prend le 4 et là c'est 5 mais puis on
prend il veut faire des six mais il y
aura tour des trois
ou alors tour des trois tours des 5 est
très fort aussi il fait roi 8 ok les
deux joueurs qui sont un petit peu c'est
normal en panique mais clairement autour
des trois tours des cinq va arriver
victoire de programme lambda on va
regarder tout de suite si on a quelque
chose à se mettre sous la dent mais
mauvaise partie de la part de Maxime là
qui clairement connaissait pas son
ouverture
qu'est-ce qu'on a comme chose
intéressante
on a
Erik easy Abdou c'est en train de faire
nul peut-être la partie ça sera entre
Vincent gamer et
tes mots Raja BOV Raja BOV excellent
joueur de Blitz les années 17 c'est
à l'époque déjà il jouait énormément il
est très très fort
et ton rêve de tour C8 et vous voyez il
veut s'activer
oui il laisse revenir mais tout autant
attention on attaque tout
on attaque tout et la finale de Tours
est-ce que tout est final le Tour sont
nul apparemment pas celle-là c'est
gagnant plutôt pour les blancs parce
qu'on va faire on va prendre et on va
pousser on peut pousser
il faut pas réfléchir en finale comme ça
il faut pousser tourage 4 peut-être
d'abord non il fait G6
et sur H2 la semaine derrière tour G2 il
va faire G7 il va menacer de prendre il
fait échec d'abord pour que le roi soit
obligé d'aller parler on va faire rouage
7 et G2 et j'ai cette pardon et j'ai
huit dames ça va être complètement
terminé
et gamer qui est en confiance qui va
certainement l'emporter
et c'est fini et c'est fini et
malheureusement un début catastrophique
pour mvl qui nous a fait tellement
plaisir dans le Blitz mais là qui est un
peu plus un peu plus en difficulté
et on voit il reste une partie ah elle
peut être marrante celle-là entre gris
Tchouk et vidyt on va aller voir on va
récupérer les deux joueurs
et c'est évidemment c'est la dernière
caméra on la voit entre gritchuk et Vidy
ouh là là de cavaliers contre fous bon
ben c'est nul on peut donner le fou
surtout
bon ça va pas où là il peut tomber
il peut tomber Sacha
ouais non là il se passerait rien 28
secondes il y a ce fois en prise
pourquoi il laisse le four en prix ça
peut vous parler de dingue mais en fait
de cavalier contre roi ça ne m'atte pas
du tout donc on s'en moque du Fou
faut qu'il y a un pion pour les blancs
pour mettre en zuban
c'est génial il enfermé le il lui en
fabriquer un livre il va être obligé de
prendre
un moment ou un autre
il est énervé mais il sourit vite
il va prendre évidemment qui va prendre
et vite il doit prendre le fou mais ça
ne suffit pas ces deux cavaliers c'est
assez injuste mais on ne mate pas et
c'est pas très dur à défendre
il suffit de pas faire de ma télé il ne
fera pas de mater des Sacha great show
que ne vous inquiétez pas pour lui il
espère peut-être un coup illégal
vite mais là ça va être ça va être
compliqué alors il essaye de mater quand
même bon c'est du bled peut-être qu'il
espère un coup illégal est-ce que le
coup illégal fait partie je sais pas je
pense qu'on en aura je crois pas
si on tombe avec deux carrés contre roi
seul c'est nul ou parti perdu c'est nul
quand l'adversaire a plus de à plus de
matériel pour vous mater c'est nul
toujours
alors comment on fait ici
je sais pas quelle est la règle est-ce
qu'on a un orbite dans la salle
est-ce qu'on a un arbitre dans la salle
qui pourrait nous dire
si
c'est maths si qu'est-ce qui se passe
c'est quoi la nouvelle règle sur le
Blitz
est-ce que
un coup illégal perd la partie ou pas
et voilà vous voyez il peut coincer dans
le coin mais après il peut pas mater
est-ce qu'il y a des pièges
il a une minute ingrédients qu'elle a
pendule ça peut durer longtemps
mais ça ne m'a pas ouais pour compter 50
coups aussi vous inquiétez pas
c'est le deuxième d'accord c'est le
deuxième qui part à la partie
rempli de souci d'accord
ok ok
combien de parties 18 dans le blizzard
donc bon
la route est longue clairement
ouais non bien sûr son objectif c'est de
se qualifier pour les candidat mais ça
fait toujours plaisir attention il prend
pas ça les à la légère on se rappelle
qu'il avait été il est champion du monde
de Blitz 2021 donc il aime ça le bled
Maxime donc ça fait jamais plaisir de
perdre
vous inquiétez pas vous inquiétez pas
c'est jamais c'est jamais un
quelque chose d'agréable
bon
il tourne
on est grisho qui fait ça très propre il
demande pas les 50 couilles il demandera
si il a un coup du mat
ouais c'est bizarre de continuer
honnêtement
honnêtement ils sont tenus quand même
ces Indiens
ils abandonnent pas à une école et une
école clairement ils abandonnent pas ils
jouent vraiment jusqu'au bout mais bon
c'est un peu l'école Carlson
je suis pas sûr que Carlson a joué la
par contre il a donc pas ses cavaliers
ça se trouve ça agaçant
il espère trouver un match mais il y en
a pas
alors on va voir
j'ai le monsieur
qui reprend son activité
ouais Sacha peut remonter à 3 minutes
c'est un peu de temps au cas où il y
aurait une question
et maintenant et maintenant comment il
fait vite non il se passe rien
il va réclamer un coup du matin si
jamais c'est maths mais ça sera pas mat
il arrive à rien c'est génial il tombe
en
c'est assez incroyable ce qui se passe
je sais pas pourquoi ouais il rigole bon
ok bon très bien
prochaine partie dans dans 4 minutes
normalement
est-ce qu'ils vont suivre ça ou pas
j'en profite pour vous faire un petit
point résultat je vais fermer la fenêtre
aussi vite 32 gamer ajabo mvl management
a perdu contre j'arrive
je vous jure qu'il coupe toujours la
même planche c'est du délire alors
Raja bof abattu gamer MBA a perdu à
Christophe surprise Abdou contre art
June nul Richie nul le classement et
bien prenez un avec deux sur deux ah
c'est possible ça soit un très bon genre
de Blitz bon le tournoi élan à Krishna
très connu pour être un bon joueur de
Blitz
glitchouk un ennemi sur deux gamers
1/200 et demi et de très grands blitzer
mvl et Raja bof à zéro sur deux c'est
que le début tout va bien
tout va bien il n'y a pas de il y a pas
de souci
alors
on va aller regarder peut-être la ronde
3 contre qui contre qui Maxime va jouer
on va découvrir ça sous vos yeux ébahis
et il joue vite il était nul alors
attention il faut lui coller une bulle à
visite hein c'est le moment de remonter
un petit peu 173 coups la partie
gretchup visite quand même Google gamer
on va se mettre comme ça
et on va aller chercher la partie de
Maxime alors est-ce qu'il va vraiment
commencer
en même temps ou pas
parce qu'on va recommencer à l'heure ou
pas ou est-ce que visite nous a mis en
retard avec son acharnement
on retourne chez qui est on va aller sur
la vue où on est bien
dites-moi d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce que vous préférez voilà
non est-ce que vous préférez
cette scène là pour suivre les blites
vous tapez 1
ou alors
cette scène là vous tapez 2 public
en VIP on va essayer de trouver Maxime
est-ce qu'il est à Maxime non ça c'est
Google
donc Maxime il est il doit être à la 3
ouais voilà Maxime
qui est là on va se mettre du côté noir
et on va se mettre sur les escaliers on
peut se mettre sur les escaliers sur
celle-là ça c'est bien ça
ça c'est pas mal quand même escaliers on
a notre petit siège
alors
j'ai là il y a beaucoup de votes là
j'ai besoin d'un
d'un j'ai besoin de quelqu'un de
confiance tata G3 bravo c'est malin de
de de de
3 1 2 1 1
plutôt de 1
égalité ayez les nazes
tu nous comptes les uns et les deux
enfin quelqu'un de confiance dans ce
chat
beaucoup de sur Youtube mais beaucoup de
deux
sur twitch donc on va faire on va faire
de
on va faire
je crois que deux gagnants est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord
ouais 2 ici d'accord d'accord merci il
est naze que l'on salut à qui on
souhaite bonne chance
bonne chance une prochaine participation
championnat du monde junior Mexique
Mexique
alors
suivra ça évidemment
et au cas de jouer par visite il avait
joué ça déjà dans le tournoi il y avait
une sorte de ninder dragonf et qu'est-ce
qui nous fait Maxime il nous joue 6 à ça
y est il rejoue un petit peu ses débuts
on a une rond solimo avec fougères sept
petits Français 6 qu'est-ce qui nous
fait il prend du pion B Maxime ça c'est
lui il veut contrôler le centre mais
c'est très risqué les blancs vont faire
ces trois des quatre en général dans ce
genre de structure
c'est très risqué il en a eu avec les
Blancs contre Magnus Carlson de ce genre
de d'ouverture donc il faut que je
change les pendules excusez-moi j'oublie
à chaque fois c'est terrible mais Maxime
Vacher La Grave là qui va connaître son
histoire beaucoup mieux que dans les
autres fois parce que là il joue un
petit peu plus sans répertoire
il fait une petite surprise à visite
mais sans se surprendre lui-même parce
que là contre Prague on a l'impression
qu'il a voulu surprendre mais à la fin
c'était un peu l'histoire de l'arroseur
arroser il joue tout revient qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ici
Maxime qui connaît déjà plus ou là ça
c'est quand même mauvais signe Tourer il
y a plein de coups E5 cavaliers F6 c'est
possible
énormément de coup c'est une question de
goût
allez
ouh là là il connaît pas du tout Maxime
aïe aïe aïe allez Maxime
ou il est pas en forme du tout tomber
vite aussi et un coup
dame C7 je crois a été joué par Magnus
aussi une option et jouer 5 5 ici je
crois que c'est un peu tôt et ces trois
jouets par visite pour jouer des 4 et ça
c'est normalement c'est des mauvaises
versions pour les Noirs mais bon on va
voir c'est pas très grave mais disons
qu'est-ce qu'il est lent aujourd'hui
Maxime va chier Lagrave qui normalement
joue plus vite que son ombre et bien une
minute de moins déjà
et normalement c'est assez mauvais ça
pour les noirs et la jauge a l'air
semble confirmer
alors comment on fait
comment on fait ici normalement c'est
tombé 8 kb3 je crois j'ai déjà joué
comme ça moi
avec les Noirs peut-être là des 6 je
crois que ça ça ouais ça doit être fou
j'ai 5 attention mascape c'est ici il va
le voir évidemment Maxime va chez
lagraphe mais
c'est voilà on est obligé de jouer des
coups comme ça adapté deux menaces fois
oh ça pourrait faire un zéro sur 3 ça
serait moche de commencer la journée
comme ça
mais bon lave on est favoris pour ça
menace quai B3 encaisse le pion tout
simplement d'un MBC il va jouer qui est
B3 automatique à mon avis
ça protège et attaque ça me semble être
le coup là ou pas
ou pas il réfléchit
et 3 jouer 3D 8 et maintenant peut-être
un petit coup de fouet à 6
intéressant je sais pas ou alors faut
trois fous des 4 ah faut trois c'est 5
attention c'est ça qui est le prochain
coup des Noirs si on laisse faire
bon ça va plus de peur que de mal dans
cette ouverture
c'est pas c'est pas dramatique
alors dame F4 et foie F6 qui arrive ouh
là ou là sur Youtube là les modérateur
va falloir bosser là
merci
YouTube merci de
[Musique]
de notre ami Simon calistré là pour moi
600 secondes
on est gentil avec tout le monde on
essaie d'être bienveillant alors c'est 5
je vais faire la police disant c'est dur
ça faisait longtemps faute si jouer
ouais c'est quand même sur case noire
c'est quand même très ah des cinq jolies
propose une petite finale puis on prend
un surplus on prend des seins qui
accueilli prendre des sacs à le mettre
du couloir à la fin alors regardez dame
prend on a l'impression que on perd une
pièce et en fait et en fait et en fait
il y a le matelas là-bas si on prend des
5 jolies et voilà c'est pour ça que
Maxime va chez La Grave a été champion
du monde de Blitz c'est parce qu'il voit
ce genre de choses en une milice
une milice secondes d'un match 4
et maintenant il est quasiment mieux
peut-être comment on fait est-ce qu'on
fait il fait ces quatre ok
Ivan que c'est B2 faut pas laisser
traîner avec mvl
est-ce que puis on prend des cinq et un
coup pour attaquer le cavalier 7 je
pense pas il y a cavalier F5
intermédiaires intéressant
intéressant tout ça
et il a rejoint il fait une très belle
il fait une très belle
fait une très belle remontée là dans
cette partie
alors ces quatre eux prendre des 5 puis
on prend mes trois tours qui marchait
j'ai pas vu puis on prend à deux mais là
ça va pas du tout ah puis on prend ah
oui sur sur mon coup de KFC 4 ok 8 et
maintenant apparemment ou dans ma carte
ça a pu être raté ça attaque la tour
attaque le pion aïe aïe aïe aïe il a pas
vu d'ailleurs on a vu la tête on a vu la
tête de Maxime je fais un petit coup de
refresh comme ça j'ai pas
et ça perd un pion et probablement c'est
compliqué ah bah au moment où j'ai dit
qu'il remontait bien
j'ai
incroyable
j'ai un peu coincé un peu beaucoup même
ah c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment ballot
c'est vraiment ballot il est mal là il
fait H5 mais bon c'est dur c'est dur
purement énorme purement pour Maxime
Hyères grave ok maintenant il faut comme
il dit il faut menacer de menacer
menaçant de menacer
il est très beau spion je voulais le
pousser mais c'est vrai que ça ouvre un
petit peu la diagonale donc vidite il
est quand même prudent il joue contre
des meilleurs buteurs au monde donc il
va doucement
on va voir on va voir on va voir c'est
pas fini
Dame des 6 Dame des trois OK
et maintenant qu'est-ce qui se passe
Tour Eiffel 5 mais bon c'est
complètement foutu attention avec
cavaliers aux quatre qui vont arriver
maintenant oh le pion voilà le petit
pion qui traîne
il a plus de temps encore 10 secondes
Maxime il est bon quand il a c'est un
signe quand il joue aussi lentement
c'est que ça va pas
évidemment propose la petite finale très
malhonnête oh il a il la prend la petite
finale très malhonnête peut-être qui
considère ouais que toute façon son roi
est trop faibles à trop peu de temps
donc c'est de la meilleure chance de
sauver mais évidemment il manque de
pions
il manque de pions donc ça va être plus
que compliqué dans cette situation de
s'en sortir
qu'est-ce qu'on fait en pouce on ramène
le roi je sais pas où on pousse ici
enfin on va probablement tout faire au
final et il fait 4 visite F6 et D6 voilà
il fait les deux et il va ramener son
roi vous inquiétez pas pour lui ah il
attaque ici F5 mais c'est un troisième
pion on y croit plus là on y croit plus
du tout ou là même pas il prend même pas
le pion il fait il pousse
alors peut-être aussi CD7 menace pousser
si seul coup à mon avis
jouer
très très mal menace cavalier F6
cavalier F4 attaque le pion menace aussi
il va faire aussi c'est intermédiaire
échec évidemment vite
la même peut-être des 7 Gan mais cavalh5
pourquoi est-ce que c'est la tête qui
avait 6 et au 7 va arriver terminé
terminé terminé ado oh là là c'est le
c'est la cata c'est la cata en ce début
de partie
alors on va voir qui on va peut-être
voir le
leader Pride face à gamer
non c'est pas là
comme d'hab
et qu'est-ce qui se passe et Praga
gagnant encore 3 sur 3 voilà il est
impressionnant il est impressionnant
impressionnant notre ami Prague je vois
pour l'instant
alors qu'est-ce qui reste Abdou contre
Raja bof que ça donne plus pour rajabov
tandis que là c'est la fin ça va faire
nul ok donc on va aller voir rajabov
contre Abdou
et
ça c'est fini je crois que c'est
celle-là
et on va
tout de suite se mettre là et mettre la
position
et tourner échiquier aussi et on a
adoucatov qui se bat comme un diable
il va encaisser le pion je crois non
et maintenant il prend
et il prend l'autre pion voilà ça joue
ça joue sur les secondes une position
archi compliquée parce que finalement il
y a deux pions passées liées mais il y a
aussi des pions passées pour les noirs
ou là qu'est-ce que ça donne ce truc
il est content il est content
visiblement il pense qu'il est gagnant
mais attention
c'est pas sûr bien joué pour faire B3
et pousser deux a été raté par
certainement
et ils prenait de la dame quelle intox
de la part des deux joueurs
oh là là c'est incroyable il va prendre
et ça va être final de dames mais ça va
faire nul oh les deux joueurs qui sont
ils ont envie de gagner je vous le dire
on a envie de gagner quoi qu'il arrive
n'importe quel il y a l'adrénaline qui
est là et donc roi contre roi on est
presque à vouloir jouer clairement
clairement
mais bon
mesdames des quatre ah d'où il prend un
légère avantage mais bon ça devrait pas
être suffisant
ou pas on va voir il pousse son pion
bien sûr qu'il faut pousser les pions
dans ce genre de cas
et les noirs sont un peu mieux alors la
jauge évidemment elle va montrer égale
jusqu'à dans longtemps mais c'est quand
même clairement les Noirs ils ont le
pion avancé
en 4 qui est beaucoup plus proche que le
pion g donc c'est les noirs qui poussent
ici
il faut juste faire attention 3 secondes
ça joue sur les secondes évidemment
des joueurs qui ont plus de temps ils
répètent non il a joué évidemment à d'où
ça torof il a bien raison
il a bien raison de la jouer
et des échecs une pluie d'échec est-ce
qu'on arrive à se cacher il va essayer
en tout cas il fait roi F4
et on voit ces deux joueurs qui sont pas
manchots du tout
en blitz
notre Amir ajabof
G4
notre ami c'est pas j'ai qu'à le pousser
et oui oui c'est ça c'est ça il faut
faire ça il a raison il a raison
la croix des quatre et je crois qu'il
peut pousser là
pas sûr et il pousse
et le roi est très proche le roi blanc
alors il va faire des échecs évidemment
ouh là là ça met entre 3 cases
et il essaie de planquer le roi derrière
le pion
parce que ça va prendre ou pas
attention à d'où ça te va
on peut la perdre aussi c'est pas
complètement ça risque
ouais
c'est plutôt malin comme ça on se pose
pas la question
et il pousse est-ce qu'il y a ces passe
de punir là
je vois ici une tentative de punition
la part de Raja va finir plus de chèque
attention ça joue
croisé de ces perdants maintenant E2 il
a voulu le punir
il a voulu le punir mais c'était assez
mal joué il va prendre le pion sur échec
certainement
et damage 5 échec arrive et ça va être
pris sur échec le pion je suppose
et c'est gagnant maintenant c'est
gagnant pour Abdou j'aurais dit fallait
faire attention ouh là là va arriver
seul coup pour pas faire dame il reprend
une dame j'adore il a il a trois dames
dans les mains
comment on fait maintenant il faut
arriver à planquer le roi
bon là le problème c'est qu'il y a plus
il y a plus de courroie géant il y a
plus d'échec et ça va être un abandon de
la part de rajabov ah c'est rageant et
zéro sur 3 pour les deux joueurs les
plus expérimentés non avec greachuk mais
bon incroyable donc qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé quelque chose qui a battukesh et
mvl a perdu Éric et Krishna demi sur
trois
et Abdou cette Europe a battu Raja bof P
Prague a battu gamer et donc le résultat
le standing Prague avec 3 sur 3 Richou 2
ennemis sur 3 avec Krishna 2 sur 3
visite 2 sur 3G Abdou gamer 1,5
mvl 0 et Raja BOV 0 on va tout de suite
aller
update notre champion français qui a 0
sur 3 ça c'est un peu dur évidemment
enfin c'est même
c'est le pire des scénarios
0 sur 3 on va aller voir tout de suite
la prochaine partie dans 4 minutes ça y
a quand même du rythme
on va aller voir tout de suite
l'appareil membre de la prochaine
on espère vraiment là
Maxime il y a plus le choix faut mettre
des points faut commencer il arrive
blanc contre gamer c'est pas mal ça a
pas l'air d'être
une terreur j'allais dire mais bon il y
a une mission 3 donc
c'est pas le plus fort quoi sans que
Prague Prague quand même va dominer cet
endroit
pral 3 sur 3 ça a l'air ça a l'air
d'être du solide
et on va essayer de retrouver de
retrouver notre ami Maxime tout de suite
je vais aussi en profiter pour ouvrir la
fenêtre chez moi parce que j'ai chaud
et j'ai l'impression qu'il y a moins de
bruit
alors moins de bruit ou pas c'est pas
je vais décaler la première
pendule et la deuxième pendule je vais
mettre là
ce sera à peu près ça
et on aura ouais on voit je crois Maxime
Vacher la grave avec les Blancs
et je peux même m'asseoir où est-ce
qu'il faut que je m'assois alors je sais
pas là
pour le faire gagner là on sait pas
c'est plus quoi faire
c'est dur
je reviens
c'est un peu ça j'ai un peu d'exters qui
habitent en face c'est ça le truc là
Monsieur les amis
j'ai un peu d'exters qui habitent en
face de chez moi là on sait pas ce qu'il
fait
mais bon c'est pas clair cette histoire
alors
on a
je croyais d'échec c'est ce que je peux
faire pareil au sud de la France
mais les deux alors charme honnêtement
j'aime bien les deux
j'aime bien changer en fait
ça suffit
ça suffit je préfère l'Alpe du S ouais
effectivement
elle peut être très sympa franchement
bien l'été on était bien
joué assez longtemps honnêtement
j'aurais préféré jouer un peu plus
longtemps mais bon c'est comme ça c'est
la vie
alors
Maxime avec les Blancs il nous faut du
E4 là il y a pas le choix Maxime sinon
ça va être la torture
sinon ça va être une torture ce tournoi
j'ai pas arrêté du coup ouais j'ai pas
arrêté de faire des randonnées
je trouve que il joue trop lentement
Maxime normalement ça se voit
ça se voit quand il est lent comme ça
c'est que il y a un petit problème après
il joue pas des positions et lesquelles
il est il est familier ouh là que j'aime
pas ça et il s'entête il sentait dans sa
catalane attention
parce que c'est d'avoir de la pratique
sur ça alors on a une variante tout à
fait logique ce fubé 4 x 7 une des
ventes principales de la Catalane
comment il va jouer Maxime
dame c'est de l'eau coup principal qui
est BD7 maintenant c'est tourner un ouf
4 ou B3 tous les coups sont à peu près
jouables ici ce qui commence à réfléchir
maintenant c'est c'est refusé
4 à 5 et ouais tous les joints
répertoire sur un catalan
je me suis trompé de pendule pardon
excusez-moi
les pendules les pendules mais vous
l'aurez compris c'est le temps des
blancs et le temps des Noirs je suis
désolé
le temps des blancs et le temps des
Noirs qui est là
et ouais là c'est très confort pour les
Noirs il y a aucun problème on a réussi
à le sortir ce fou on va jouer tour C8
on préfère même les Noirs en me lasse et
G4 il va jouer tour C8 évidemment gamer
a très très rapidement il est habitué
et en faire
il veut essayer quelque chose est-ce que
c'est 5 marches là c'est la question que
gamer va se poser pas très longtemps
il le fait
ouais mais non mais là en rapide encore
on peut essayer des choses mais en blitz
faut jouer quand même sur ces réflexes
je pense
je pense que c'est un mauvais choix là
de répertoire et d'ailleurs ça je vous
ai tout en lui qui joue tellement vite
d'habitude
et bien il prend beaucoup de temps parce
qu'il y a des positions qui connaît pas
donc je conseillerais un changement
rapide de style et d'ouverture
bon là ça va encore c'est jouable
mais bon les noirs sont confort il y a
pas de doute
F3 normalement même un petit cavalier en
4 il veut faire que 5 je suppose Maxime
il peut se faire quasiment non il fait
dame 7
très solide très solide Vincent
ah ça y est ça y est on commence à
critiquer
il faut pas critiquer quand même parce
que franchement il a été il était
impérial dans le rapide alors il y a
peut-être changement de stratégie rapide
il jouait beaucoup plus ses ouvertures
c'est que ça joue moins en blitz mais
quand même quand même quand même quand
même
tu relâchement aussi peut-être
et puis des forgeurs en face clairement
et puis c'est pas fini
c'est surtout ça aussi
donc
ça peut arriver mais c'est vrai que on
aimerait bien une petite une petite
remontée là
ça me prend des quatre peut-être fou
c'est 5 c'est très confort pour les
noirs
on l'a vu dans les deux de trois
premières là il était quand même assez
mal au temps assez vite ce qui est pas
du tout coutumier et c'est pas
simplement les ouvertures c'est le type
de position après qui joue qui
m'inquiète plus type de position sur
lesquelles il est pas il a pas une
expérience dingue
voilà donc en blitz
c'est une question de réflexe quand même
alors x 3 tours C2
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire il réfléchit un
peu gamer ça c'est bon pour nous
il est quand même il était mieux préparé
ça c'est une évidence gamer mais il est
moins bien longtemps donc 20 secondes
d'avance pour Maxime Vacher la grave ça
c'est bien parce que ça c'est tout lui
ça c'est comme ça qui gagnait partie il
met une pression autant et après dans le
dans les secondes finales et bien il est
tellement rapide tellement vif
tactiquement que normalement il emballe
il emballe la partie et là c'est gamer
il sait pas il sait pas qu'il est en
train de
de creuser sa propre tombe avec cette
réflexion
alors foutez ça à côté mais là contre
contre mvl avec peu de temps c'est
injouable ça devient vite un jouable
il a gagné en rapide assez étoral Blitz
tout à fait tout à fait pour l'instant
bon mais c'est vous le voyez c'est une
catastrophe
mais
ça pourrait revenir ça peut vite tourner
c'est tout à lui
et on peut faire des séries on a vu
Magnus ou Maxime faire des 8 9 victoires
consécutives ou la Dame des trois ça se
met dans les clouages ça a pas l'air
extraordinaire
et tourner 8 évidemment on recrée
vis-à-vis très désagréable pour les
blancs
elle est pas facile cette position et il
attaque et c'est 5 maintenant il peut
prendre ici et il va avoir une position
au minimum à quoi que ça peut donner des
des choses comme ça
mais il le fait quand même aider 4 il
veut faire qui est ici ça y est c'est
parti on est parti en mode arnaque mais
bon déjà ça coûte un pion mon avis ça
marche pas du tout son truc là a l'air
d'adhérer au projet que ça marche pas du
tout il prend en B3 il le sait Maxime
c'est pas terrible 7 oh là quelle
solidité de la part de gamer là
Maxime qui se prend les pieds dans le
tapis
alors que c'est dur
que c'est dur
et tours c'est enclos mais on menace
rien ce cavalier bien ancré en C5 avec
ce pur à 5 on peut plus faire à 3 B4 on
a perdu un pion c'est un désastre
ouais
ça je me reconnais dans ce genre de coup
la carte propose une finale avec un pion
de plus
et ouais maintenant maintenant on se bat
pour la nul hein clairement avec les
Blancs
vous savez ce qu'on va faire la
prochaine on va aller voir Prague on va
pas regarder Maxime
voilà et on va voir si il gagne on a
plus Maxime
faut faire un truc là faut qu'on change
un truc parce que là ça va pas
on est d'accord ou pas
on va aller voir Prague parce que Prague
s'il est surtout s'il a 4 sur 4
il faut il faut faire quelque chose et
là il a un pur de moins net alors
évidemment ça peut se sauver ce genre de
position mais on joue pour deux
résultats 17 secondes pour gamer
tour à 4 il fait tomber de il protège
son cavalier
et on revient par là ah ouais on
pourrait récupérer le pion direct ou pas
ah attention alors
très agréable pour la tour peut-être en
casser 6 cavalier 7 j'en sais rien pour
ces 7 d'abord ouh là là mais ça ça
rigole pas là ça joue très serré gamer
qui a surtout envie de pas perdre
mais ça va être compliqué de progresser
honnêtement
comment on fait aimer ses cavaliers
attention plus que 10 secondes pour
gamer ça peut lui jouer des tours
et aux quatre menace ou 5 ouh là là
attention peut-être un retournement on a
menacé de bouder de de plus le regarder
et voilà ce qui s'est passé trois quatre
est une gaffe au 5 a une pièce et voilà
voilà il s'est laissé trop peu de temps
et il va tomber
et des faits il est tombé il est tombé
incroyable alors qu'il était
complètement gagnant
ça fait plaisir cette victoire on va
aller voir une autre partie vite fait
qu'est-ce qui se passe qu'est-ce qui se
passe sur les autres parties
ça sera vraiment le grand favori du
tournoi
Prague contre Abdou satorov qu'on voit
là on va mettre le score de Maxime à
jour il fait plaisir quand même ce petit
point pas vraiment
pas vraiment une partie archid dominée
mais ça peut être un tournant comme
compte vide le premier jour on s'en
souvient rapide
voilà c'est mieux c'est mieux déjà sur 4
en over
une catalane
qui c'est pas très bien passé on voit
pra qui joue la gagne encore une fois oh
là là
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé là on a plus
les coups
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il a perdu un
pion dans un F3 il y a eu tout reprend
il perd un pion Prague
non pardon il est complètement gagnant
et le roi va se faufiler c'est terminé
on va essayer de passer les faut essayer
de passer la tour derrière mais il va
pas y arriver il va retourner vite tour
à 8 donc du coup il a les petites
chances de s'en tirer à tour derrière là
c'est un désastre il va faire tomber
trois tours G3 et 4 ouais c'est terminé
c'est complètement fini
il peut faire tout ce qu'il veut la
Kassim j'allais dire à d'où ça torov
Cassi mais c'est l'ancien l'ancien
ouzbek le premier qui a été des
champions du monde de ma génération
du monde mais quand même
et qui est le coach de Sator ça va ça va
abandonner
ça va abandonner et c'est terminé et on
a un score parfait il est incroyable
il est incroyable notre ami
alors on a vite vite bouquet alors eux
ils sont tenus comme tout l'un comme
l'autre
et on voit Abdou qui remet ses pièces
alors Google qui a les noirs
contre-visite qui est mieux et pourquoi
c'est les Noirs parce qu'on a un bon
pion passé là
et comment on fait on attaque le ah la
la
pour être pas mal tout ça
ouais on dit qu'on regarde plus Maxime
mais on le regarde quand même ouais
voilà c'est ça la stratégie ok on
regarde plus Maxime
surtout à la prochaine partie on ne
regardera pas Maxime je vous le garantis
en boude on veut que ça joue mieux donc
on va voir on va voir ailleurs on va
voir ailleurs
on regarde pas du tout Maxime
et qu'est-ce qui se passe là il a gaffe
est apparemment vite
voilà ça nous fait un tour avec le
contour ça a joué 350 coups
ça va être extraordinaire
regarde ça à voir sans voir
de partir en même temps ça va être
compliqué quand même
on va pas faire ça peut-être est-ce
qu'il gagne ou pas
non non ce qui va se passer c'est que le
cavalier va très certainement se
sacrifier ou à moins qu'il y a perpète
là Google
et nul entre les deux joueurs on va vite
voir les résultats de la ronde et enfin
enfin en fin de première victoire alors
un peu
un peu capillotracté cette victoire de
mvl mais bon elle fait plaisir on la
prend et Prague
Prague avec les noirs qui va à d'où ça
torof le reste nul
un sur quatre
et donc
[Musique]
on voit le score Prague 4 sur 4 pouf
incroyable 3 sur 4 pour greatchouk très
solide triple champion du monde de Blitz
donc attention ça joue sérieux visité
avec deux et demi et gazy
[Musique]
2k1 qui quitte la dernière place et on
va regarder tout de suite le
les appareils
regarde pas on le regarde pas du tout
on ne regardera pas ça
on prévient
on prévient Maxime on ne regarde pas
cette partie
on ne regarde pas cette partie faut que
ça joue mieux faut que ça fasse plus de
points voilà on va se mettre du côté
noir quand même
pour être sûr on sait jamais changer
d'avis
allez
on peut changer d'avis
on sait pas on va regarder sur quelle
caméra il va être la prochaine partie
dans 6 minutes
je crois
on va voir en tout cas je vais faire une
micropose de 4 minutes là en ouvrant la
fenêtre et revenir je fais une micro
pause à mi parcours je crois qu'il y a
pas de
je pense pas qu'il y ait de pause il y a
18 rondes dans ce tournoi de parties
de Blitz et ça reprend dans 5 petits
minutes je reviens dans trois petites
minutes je vous dis à tout de suite
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechess ou
les titles Tuesday
chase.com/aventure tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
et je suis de retour non on va retrouver
Maxime
tableau 1
avec
les pendules au bon endroit on espère on
n'est pas sûr
on va voir tout ça évidemment qu'on va
regarder Maxime machinagrave c'est sur
deux jours c'est aller-retour donc il y
a le temps de se refaire il y a 18
rondes on est même pas au tiers donc on
se détend
on se détend il faudrait l'emporter
évidemment sur cette partie chaque point
est bon à prendre on va voir ce que ça
donne Google ça doit être pas mal hein
ça doit être pas mal Google
on va voir
ouais mais il a l'air un peu fatigué
depuis le début non mais ça va il faut
qu'il joue il joue un peu un peu plus
vite c'était bien là
c'était quand même beaucoup mieux contre
gamer même s'il a il a perdu un pion
mais il a bien mis la machine arnaque
et donc il a marqué son premier point
faudrait faire un petit un petit rush
alors
qu'est-ce que ça va donner
ouais aussi peut-être qui change un
petit peu ce répertoire mais il a pas
l'air parti sur ce mode là dans cette
journée peut-être qu'il y aura un
ajustement ce soir mais je crois que
pour aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas forcément jouer son
répertoire à moins avec son expérience
il peut aussi s'adapter très rapidement
aux événements ça commence dans une
minute
les camions qui passent dans la rue
l'enfer et les quatre et on va remettre
la pendule évidemment j'ai la poisse
c'est toujours du mauvais côté
et qu'est-ce qui joue il joue encore
aussi c'est encore une carte bad hein
il joue ce gamin avec Kebe 17 ok ok donc
proposition de carsbad
accepter par visite FF4 il fait full B4
3 cavaliers E4 OK ou là c'est très chaud
ça ça menace du G5 ça m'a du cahier
prend C3
c'est intéressant et il fait j'ai 5 ok
il a l'air de savoir ce qu'il fait dans
celle-là
j'ai déjà regardé ce truc là
H5 c'est le coup
H5 Maxime
H5 une fois H5 2 fois
H5
fois non il le fait pas
allez
ça il devrait connaître
il devrait connaître
et non et voilà qui change tout de suite
son fusil d'épaule
elle est terrible cette jauge
et fous des trois on voit maintenant un
petit roc va arriver on va menacer de
prendre le 4 allez joue cahier des deux
aussi c'est pas mal ça sur quel il prend
des deux il y a fou point F5 je suppose
ouais d'accord ils sont inversés mais
bon normalement si on clique sur le
bouton première ligne on s'en sort quand
même avec les avec les noirs
ok à 3 bon là je n'aime pas du tout à
trois mais il a perdu 40 secondes dans
l'opération
c'est ça le vrai problème c'est
qu'évidemment que une petite erreur est
rattrapable en blitz mais le problème
c'est le temps il prend 4 est-ce qu'on
joue est-ce qu'on prend du Fou du pion
c'est ça la question
peut-être du fou quand même non il prend
du pion ou là
et la jauge n'aime pas du tout vous
voyez la Mouv' reflexe de position
malheureusement ça se sent ça se sent un
petit peu
qu'il est pas bien
qui connaît pas
ça change du gambida va accepter et de
la grande Feld bon il essaye des trucs
certes mais quand même
alors on se met là
et H4 il fait grand rock ouais il joue
ça de manière très dynamique bon et puis
on prend G5 certes
puis on prend j'ai 5 je suppose et le
coup mais où est-ce qu'on met trois
certainement on va devoir le laisser au
centre et Maxime qui a l'air content
qu'il y a du jeu
alors ces quatre
qui est là c'est logique on n'empêche
qu'il y ait des cinq on prend de
l'espace
fujetti j'ai pas la ref mais ça protège
le fou pourquoi pas
et voir
attendre que les Blancs donnent
l'adresse de leur roi
pas évident à jouer honnêtement
et à 4 ou à 4 à 5 et oui il tente tout
de suite une attaque à l'aile dame
c'est pas folichon pour maximiser ou
quoi sur A4 ouais ça a été raté ça a été
complètement raté à 4
et c'est pas on gagne un temps puis on
va faire à 6 et le roi va être fait le
tour prendre des quatre on l'a sur pion
3 allez alors apparemment c'est pas du
tout correct mais ça le mérite d'être un
bon coup de Blitz où ça chauffe
ça mérite d'être drôle
à 5 et il fait tourner 8 intermédiaires
attaque le cavalier ou là
ouh là ça chauffe
il y a plus on prend la tête là ton
prends c'est de dames et chèques et on
ramasse la tour
je vois pas ce qu'il veut surpris à
oh là là ça a été raté par Maxime puis
on prend un 7 incroyable et oui faisons
la tête et il tapote
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe ça perd une tournée
ça perd une tournée
et oui il prend un peu de temps goûter
chez une minute mais là avec une tour de
plus
avec une tour de plus c'est complètement
terminé
MBK échec obligé mais roi F1 roi de la
tour par là elle est terminée cette
partie
ça va abandonner chez le champion
français qui fait le nom de la tête qui
a cassé abandon abandon on va aller voir
Prague
dommage là vraiment il sort pas
d'ouverture
et je vous ai truc il est pas habitué il
prend des mauvaises décisions
allez on va voir Prague
on va essayer de trouver
c'est pas lui
non plus
mais on a Prague ici avec les Blancs
face à
on va tourner chez qui
et Prague une nouvelle fois
qui apparemment très bien selon la jauge
mais bon ça reste chaud 30 secondes
contre une minute avec les chiens qui
fait un bon début de tournoi
fallait pas regarder on regarde pas la
prochaine c'est la seule c'est ma faute
la prochaine on va regarder Prague
on regarde Prague dans la prochaine
et on voit on voit si ça passe ou pas
après il a l'air vraiment décidé
il est très fort en blitz
et là c'est pas facile à jouer pour les
Noirs où est-ce qu'on met se fout en C6
peut-être mais cavaliers F5 va arriver
aussi peut-être qu'elle prend ses 6
d'abord
bref c'est la cata
B6
attaquant la dame et on va à la reculer
tranquillement
par pragon va voir avec peu de temps il
a peu de temps à la pendule on va voir
s'il va s'en tirer ou pas et cavalier F5
évidemment ouh là là
il a 6 oh là si on prend il y a le
double échec échec double ramasse la
dame on attaque F7 ça ne va pas du tout
pour i Krishna oh là il se prend tous
les coups du tennis
oh là là c'est vraiment
c'est la totale là il peut abandonner
moi j'ai 8 hyper une pièce aussi simple
que ça il prend cavalier il peut
abandonner il va le faire non il la joue
voilà ils sont tenus
ils sont tenus il fait cavalier F3 ok
mais c'est une pièce de moins et la
fourchette voilà c'est vraiment c'est
affreux ce qui s'est pris par les
cavaliers notre ami Harry Krishna allez
on va voir
on va voir ce qui se passe
Prague qui est vraiment très très
impressionnant
il y a eu entre Raja BOV et on va voir
peut-être irriguez ici qu'on a pas vu
depuis le début
on a vu passer par là
et on va tourner chez tout de suite
visite qu'on a vu pendant 170 coups face
à
gritchouk et là qu'est-ce que ça donne
ça donne trois pions pour une pièce
enfin deux
pions mais voilà on perd celui-là
et ce genre de truc c'est archi nul
normalement
mais est-ce que les deux joueurs vont
être d'accord c'est ça la question et
qui va jouer pourquoi c'est quand même
plutôt les noirs qui jouent pour quelque
chose normalement ce pur là et quand et
condamné il est d'ailleurs perdu
mais on a une forteresse ici avec les
avec les Blancs on met une tour en G5
une tour en G5 un pion H4 et on bouge
plus
non il met la tour en G4 ok c'est pareil
c'est le même concept
c'est tout à fait
le même concept
ou la qu'est-ce qu'il a fait non non il
a pas mis la tour en prison
évidemment qu'il a pas mis à toi en
prise et joueur a du mal à leur pièce
donc on va update malheureusement notre
ami mvl qui
fait le toile beats il y a pas d'autres
mots
sur 5 rendez-vous compte je sais pas si
ça lui déjà arrivé
mais en tout cas c'est une grosse
surprise une grosse immense déception
après le temps de partir rapide après
rien n'est terminé
on va arrêter de le regarder pour une
partie au moins
on va voir si il gagne on regarde pas
on va regarder Prague est très très
impressionnant franchement c'est pas
tant ce qui nous fait Prague depuis le
début avec un score je crois qu'il a 4
et demi sur 5 là
vite qui joue avec le feu comme d'hab il
a envie de gagner vite
mais alors il est prêt à prendre des
risques de dingue à chaque fois
et attention même avec peu de temps il
faut qu'il joue un coup là quand même
vite
et il a joué
il a joué mais attention il jouait le
feu j'ai l'impression ça prend du monde
oh là là ça pendule
mais apparemment il a joué il y a un
petit problème de retransmission là il a
5 sur 5 Prague oh là là
il nous fait une démonstration là
l'échiquier ne suit plus les joueurs on
peut deviner les coûts on voit pas hyper
bien mais on devine les coups
je vais essayer de refresh tout ça
pour voir si ça marche
et ça remarche
ça remarche non pas du tout ça en marche
pas du tout
donc 4 secondes chacun et visite qui a
quand même progressé il faut en prise là
non ah oui mais il y avait il y avait
maths oula attention et à gazic s'est
mis dans un réseau de maths
et vous dites qu'il a joué à fond il
peut pas reprendre
et on va avoir ton faux compte tour
on va avoir ton faux compte tour et le
roi déjà dans le coin
voilà ça doit être gagnant ça
ça doit être gagnant
et sur trois maintenant on va essayer de
menacer de pousser le pion
il avance avec son roi attention
le fameux
et on a toujours pas de
regarder moi ça
on a toujours pas à l'écoute mais on est
en voie sur échiquier le temps fou
contre
on va voir comment il va le défendre et
il est quand même déjà dans le dur
c'est dur à défendre
il faut qu'il joue des coups attention
de pas la perdre au temps
ouais il monte avec le roi effectivement
il a bien raison
c'est dur à défendre clairement
mais il va bien et il y arrive
et oui ça y est il est à la bonne
méthode de défense ah oui la connais
celle-là et sur roi des 5 Féro F8
et il va dans l'autre sens c'est ça
c'est ça
c'est exactement ça qu'il faut faire
et 17 secondes il va encore pas la
gagner vite hein
c'est encore compliqué
allez il va remettre voilà il va
remettre le roi cette position
il sait exactement comment faire
bon on a le temps au moins qui est bon
mais pas la position
on a toujours pas la position
bon a priori il la défend quand même
très très bien avec beaucoup d'assurance
vous voyez le roi est reparti de l'autre
côté
je suis désolé
je suis désolé il y a un bruit
incroyable on prépare les JO à Paris
on prépare les JO d'été
on est pas loin des 50 couleurs non je
sais pas du coup j'ai pas le compteur
mais bon il réclamera au moment où il
sera foutu
parce que dans le feu de l'action comme
ça c'est très compliqué de se rendre
compte
si on est à combien de coups on est
ouais
et sur roi des 4 il va faire tout Rachid
il faut 4 et 4
et voilà on en est toujours au même
point
et bon ça va faire du ça va faire nul je
vois vraiment pas comment il peut en
plus il a défend tellement bien et
tellement vite avec tellement
d'assurance qui gagne du temps
c'est dur d'imaginer quoi que ce soit en
cette partie
très très bien
non mais là là bon ça a été
je pense que ils sont en train de
dépasser un leur côté cool
il demande il fait une réclamation il
dit 50 coups
il dit 50 coups alors qu'est-ce qui va
se passer
oh
ouais ouais ouais ouais
75 coups
le l'arbitre doit
obligation d'intervenir mais c'est là ça
faisait plus de 50 coups c'est clair
résultat Google chabattu mvl en 25 coups
Éric et nul on vient de le voir continue
son incroyable séquence on a vu qu'il a
rendu fou avec Krishna avec ses
cavaliers et gamer abattu Abdou sa torov
on va regarder le classement
malheureusement et on voit Prague avec
cinq sur cinq autant pour moi il a 5 sur
5 Prague deuxième 3 et demi visite 3 et
demi Google gamer 2 et demi
à d'où ça torov un et demi et rajabov et
mvl un point on va regarder les
appareils
2 la prochaine partie
donc là on rentre 6 on rappelle que
demain et à jour 2 quand on suit quoi
qu'il arrive à partir de 10h30
et on voit à Cristina gamer grichu
Prague bon ben voilà on regarde quelque
chose Prague et on a mvl abdos à torov
allez on va pas alors on essaie une
partie comme ça on regarde quelque chose
vraiment pour de bon tout en je vais
quand même garder un œil sur mon
téléphone sur la partie de mvl
et je vous dirai mais on va regarder
greaque cette fois
parce que on n'a pas vu de parties là ça
nous agace ça nous agace
cette histoire
Richou Prague
et après évidemment on reviendra sur
maximum le laisse peut-être gagner une
partie
allez Maxime
on espère
exactement alors j'ai vu des questions
le genre le score max c'est quoi c'est
18 sur 18
ouais alors emineo ouais effectivement à
l'époque il y avait des
vidéos les précurseurs diagonales télé
canal web dans les années 2000
effectivement j'étais avec Stéphane et
loi
qui sont toujours dans les échecs
à différents postes
ah on a quelque chose
Prague mais qui sont évidemment restés
des passionnés avec les lois évidemment
Edouard Hollande qui est le président de
la Fédération française des échecs qui
étaient un précurseur dans ce
dans c'est commenter en direct notamment
avec le match chronique Kasparov avec
Stéphane Laborde le duo qui est
maintenant dans le sud
Stéphane si vous vous écoutez salut
amicale aux deux évidemment des bons
souvenirs canal web ces années 2000
les années 2000 les commentaires déjà à
l'époque
avenue de Wagram
Zaki Brown ouais il est président de la
FFE tandis que Stéphane Laborde s'occupe
d'un club
ah je sais plus exactement
donc là d'un comité départemental je
crois
voilà c'était bien sympa avenue de
Wagram des boloco
l'émission d'échec était la deuxième la
plus regardée de CanalWeb donc c'était
du du
Web 1.0 vraiment c'était les débuts des
le début des internets
et donc c'était la deuxième émission la
plus regardée il y a la cuisine tout ça
et elle aussi des questions moi je me
rappelle c'est club de Perpignan pour
Stéphane d'accord merci
et en fait le truc c'était ce qui était
plus regardé c'était le
l'émission de Brigitte Lahaie pour ceux
qui ont la ref ou les auditeurs posaient
des questions
vous pouvez imaginer sur
[Musique]
les le sexe l'amour
plutôt le sexe je crois d'ailleurs donc
voilà et les échecs étaient numéro 2
alors on va tourner les pendules arrêter
de parler de Brigitte Lahaie
et moins de
les moins de les moins de 30 ans n'ont
pas l'arrêt
et avec les Blancs
exactement
l'ancien actrice porno effectivement
alors fouger 5
grichu
b46 fois h4k6 attaque le pion je me
retrouve à parler de ça
mais c'est vrai tout ce que je dis est
vrai
et Sacha qui commence à réfléchir
on va jeter un coup d'œil si ça chauffe
chez Maxime ou s'il est bien on va le
voir tout de suite je vais regarder
évidemment Maxime je vais mettre ça sur
mon téléphone mais faites pareil que moi
vous pouvez voir sur chaise 24 c'est en
direct
il a joué un système de Londres comment
faire
regardez une minute au sixième coup ne
faites pas ça à la maison faut pas du
tout faire ça mais bon quelque chose
c'est comme ça il y a rien à faire pour
jouer un coup car il f-3 voilà on
s'attendait pas Sacha
et maintenant
c'est ça
alors j'ai cinq fougères et A3 attaque
le fou
intéressant
parce que si on bougeait le cavalier
avec cavalier 4 qui est arrivé donc à
réfléchit à tout ça et ça peut être très
vite c'est très dangereux ce qu'il fait
Prague très ambitieux en même temps à 5
sur 5 il y a de quoi prendre la
confiance
alors vous êtes cavalier 5 certainement
quoi d'autre qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire
d'autre Sacha
qui prend des quatre trois voilà et le
cavalier doit reculer et on peut se
venger sur ce petit pion en G4 et on a
l'air pas mal avec les Blancs j'aime
bien en tout cas
et on regarde la pendule
regardez pendules la pendule gris de
chouk il est pas bien déjà mais bon
Prague après un peu de temps quand même
un petit peu surpris
MC2 fous des trois
et grand rock c'est ça le plan
mais pas grand chose et on va faire
fouder 7 on va encaisser en G3 on va
faire dame 7 et on va être confort avec
les noirs
il faut des trois jouets et puis on
prend j'ai trois oui il faut des 7 il va
faire de la Mosset et grand rock c'était
évident
et les Noirs grâce à ce fou qui
rayonnent sur cette grande diagonale
maxime est bien
vraiment
on bluff pas vous voyez bien il est bien
content c'est bon ça
on a la paire de fou on a un très beau
centre
les noirs sont mieux on peut jouer
fousser 8 automatique ou C6 dessins mais
plutôt c'est 8 pas d'histoire ouais
c'est jouer par le jeune Prague
qui quand même fait
on impose dans ce tournoi 5 sur 5 c'est
pas donné à tout le monde
qui est béton on veut faire cavalier à 5
et créer des menaces C6 je vous en
parlais pour faire des cinq jouets
contre ce fou et on fait parler notre
centre
peut-être pas tout de suite des cinq
peut-être un petit coup de préparation
comme fougée 7 moi j'aime bien mettre le
four G7 comme ça ça libère la tour de la
protection du pion H6 mais des cinq ok
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'il va faire il
reprend de ce pion effectivement ça
libère ce fou aussi donc c'est pas mal
du tout pour les noirs
Maxime le gagnant
alors est-ce qu'il est vraiment gagnant
Maxime non pas du tout il est pas
gagnant
encore une très belle position j'aime
beaucoup avec quelque chose qui se met
mal au temps mais ça il est tellement
habitué il m'a fait tellement de coup
dans ces j'ai joué de nombreuses fois
Sacha dans les toiles Blitz champion du
monde de Blitz où ce genre de tournoi
il m'a fait nombre de coups qui m'a joué
une seconde vous y croyez à chaque fois
qui va tomber et il tombe jamais c'est
l'enfer
et je vais encore des bons coups c'est
ça aussi le problème
allez
allez Maxime ensuite du coin de l'oeil
on va voir mais en tout cas Prague
est-ce qu'il a réussi à faire parler sa
paire de fou peut-être ouvrir le jeu
avec des 4 un moment ou un autre non je
vous en parler de ce fou G7 très logique
on le recul on protège le pion h on se
crée des dames F6 et la tour oulala
Sacha qui va attaquer en même temps il a
pas trop d'autres plans et peut-être
échanger les fous de casse blanche avec
Fougères
OK
ou la tour à 4 on envoie la tour
la tour de l'autre côté
et 20 secondes entre 40
on va voir ce que ça donne
allez on va voir Maxime on change d'avis
sur quel thème Maxime
non
plus
allez au revoir Maxime vite fait
Prague j'ai l'impression qu'il va encore
gagner Prague
alors Maxime la fin de la partie de mvl
on craque on craque sous la pression
on a envie de voir ce que ça donne 40
secondes pour Maxime contre 26
pour Prague
et ça joue
avec un pion passé
mais franchement le pion est passé ouais
faut protéger la dame on a la paire de
fou on est un peu mieux mais pas tant
que ça
pas tant que ça
Maxime face à
la salle en grand on peut pas tout
mettre
et il échange Abdou il sent qu'il va
sauver la finale et malheureusement
j'ai l'impression que c'est le cas
ça me prend ou là
oulala
c'est le problème quand même des bits où
ça double mal
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il y a deux
tours
avec une tour pour fou cavalier et ça
devrait être nul c'est sur une seule l
ça va être nul c'est quasi certain
c'est quasi certain que ça va faire nul
en tout cas Maxime je pense il peut pas
trop gagner c'est pas lui qui joue la
gagne
pour essayer de se débarrasser de ça non
peut-être qu'il joue la gagner alors
peut-être
ouh là il s'est pris une tactique
il s'est pris une tactique il l'a pas vu
mais il a du bol parce qu'il peut faire
ranger 7 oh là là
et maintenant il faut s'organiser à pas
perdre du matériel ou il y a pas de ton
C6 là il y a pas tous ces 6 sur qui
avait C8 il y a échec il fait 5 il y a
une qualité
et surtout prends et F6
et on voit
voilà
il a pas vu maintenant les blancs sont
mieux sur ton reproi avec cavalier F5
échec c'était ça la pointe les blancs
sont mieux maintenant
et voilà ça y est
ça y est les blancs sont mieux la petite
arnaque
on les aime ces petites arnaques
et attention à pas se prendre H4 ça
pourrait être méchant
dans de bonnes conditions avec un
cavalier qui bondit un F4 sur H4
qu'est-ce qu'il veut il veut peut-être
F4 ouais c'est ça
obligé de faire F4 et il prend
4 mais là il est foutu quelle arnaque de
mvl incroyable ah ouais ouais quand même
ouais même quand il est pas en forme
c'est vrai qu'il a une vitesse de calcul
assez impressionnante
et maintenant il pousse il y a cavalier
H4 qui va arriver
dans le même tempo et il pousse d'abord
et maintenant c'est la technique c'est
gagné en facilement il le sait la tour
va être obligé de se sacrifier quand le
pion
ça crée Maxime ça peut redonner
confiance ça peut être un tournant
effectivement
on a parlé aussi tout à l'heure du
tournant mais là elle est elle est belle
celle-là elle fait plaisir parce qu'il y
avait vraiment aucune chance de gagner
au départ et maintenant ça gagne ça
gagne tout seul pour un joueur du
calibre et de la technicité de Maxime va
chez Lagrave
jure le Matsu cavaliers en live mais ça
va être fait en 10 secondes atchou ne
t'inquiète pas pour ça
il y a aucun souci là-dessus tu peux
déjà on peut déjà signer si affou
cavalier contre contre roi il y a
absolument zéro chance que Maxime
n'arrive pas à mater
ça va être ça va être fait en très peu
de temps
je vous garantis il faut arriver à ça
sans rien donner
cavalier
peut-être un petit échec là et on vient
avec le roi non il fait au F5
il menace F7 il va faire réussir non moi
j'ai 6 c'est bien il se plante le roi F7
maintenant F7 fousser 5 c'est terminé
va-t-il jouer il faut qu'avec les
contours on va rigoler on va rigoler
parce que moi je vous dis que ça va pas
duré longtemps cette histoire
oh il ajoute j'adore
au prochain coup il va abandonner à 7h
victoire de Maxime machinagrave on
regarde ça
et qu'est-ce qui se passe et ce qui
reste des parties en cours ou pas
on va voir ça tout de suite et bien non
tout est fini et c'est la première nul
de
Prague victoire de Harry Krishna face à
gamer visite bar à jabbov Google
un petit point sur le classement Prague
toujours qui Caracol en tête 5 et demi
sur 6 4 sur 6 pour quelque chose 4 sur 6
pour visite
3,5
gamer 2 et demi et le français en
embuscade deux points sur 6 bon c'est
pas extraordinaire mais que voulez-vous
c'est mieux que rien
et c'était mieux que zéro sur 3
bien sûr 5 c'est pour ça qu'on va
changer le score pour un petit 2 sur 6
et ça serait bien de mettre le turbo là
de finir allez si on finit la joie à 50%
on est pas mal quand même on est pas si
mal allez on retente Maxime dès le début
j'ai peur je vais me faire je vais me
faire gronder Maxime aura les Noirs
contre art June
erikazy
la sélection pour des joueurs comme ça
elle se fait au bon vouloir
d'organisateur
il nous reste trois ondes ce que je vais
faire je vais me faire un petit café moi
je sais pas vous petit café
la prochaine dans 5 minutes ça enchaîne
bien
ensuite Maxime on est revenu le voir il
est arnaqué là c'est bon on s'en veut
plus tout à l'heure
et on espère qu'il va
aller en signe pour un 2 et demi sur
trois
et on se dit que
et bien c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal non pas terrible mais au
début de la journée on aurait pas signé
du tout pour 50% mais on reste on reste
en course un café avec sucre pareil
pareil ici petit café
petite tasse qui nous vient de graisse
en plus c'est pas beau ça franchement
allez
petit café je reviens la pub cheescom
pour ceux qui sont encore
qui vont qui vont rester qui boivent pas
de café et voilà trois rentes de Blitz à
venir et demain on enchaîne avec une
offre on est à partir de 10h30 à tout de
suite
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surplus a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechess ou
les title twist dead
cheese.com/avent scoop tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroulent
en présentiel ou en ligne vivez
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
et nous avons mvl nous sommes de retour
nous allons avoir mvl tout de suite avec
les Noirs je mets des escaliers face à
Arjun
erikazy
le jeune joueur indien
a fort gagné faut mettre la machine
arnaquer en route là
rappelle Maxime très très mauvais début
de tournoi de Blitz avec zéro sur 3
c'est un peu mieux là depuis 3 ans 2 sur
3 avec des arnaques
petites arnaques là mais c'est pas
encore complètement
convaincant pour être honnête
on va voir on va voir tout ça
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire alors ça joue
le 4 c'est 5 utile
et c'est parti qu'est-ce qui va jouer
cahier des cinq ou à une des ventes les
plus critiques évidemment
et il joue ce coup kb8 et d'un meuf 3 ou
là ça c'est une ligne de Blitz attention
menace dame C3 et qui est C7 donc là
faut faire très attention je pense qu'il
faut jouer à six selon mes souvenirs
on les pendule pardon pardon pardon
pardon autant pour moi autant pour moi
les pendules et ouais
pour le Blitz
mais attention c'est très dur à jouer en
vie de cette ligne ouh là là
il a bien raison
il a bien raison fou des deux menaces
fois 5 peut-être non x 5 ça va pas donc
là on va ok gentiment et on va jouer
cahier des 7 comme d'hab attention pion
quand même 4 menace et le pion des 6
on connaît pas ce genre de ligne ça peut
être très très dangereux et rock mais
bon c'est le style de Maxime quand même
donc c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal
mais bon le problème c'est encore une
fois 30 secondes de moins la pendule et
il a l'air de connaître encore
énorme sacrifice de qualité c'est avec
la dame est un peu enfermée là
à 8 mais il a l'air de tellement bien
connaître et
ça rigole pas alors on veut sortir par
là avec la dame est-ce qu'on fait dame
B6 ou pas
mesdames
alors comment on peut faire pour jouer
on peut aussi jouer faut protéger espion
quand même donc comment on fait j'en
sais rien
j'en sais rien maxime a pas l'air de
savoir non plus
est-ce qu'il va faire dame B6 j'ai
l'impression qu'il va faire des MBC 3
dans ma salle échec peut-être
ouf
et ouais c'est ça le problème
regardez
c'est sûr
incroyable
normalement bon pour les Noirs mais bon
faut encore le savoir ça marche en bide
il y a pas on n'a pas le temps de
réfuter en bide c'est ça le problème une
trame d'avance pourrait réglerie ça
commence à devenir inquiétant cette
histoire faux 6
il va pas se prendre la fuite là et puis
on prend le 6
après j'aime bien il faut prendre les 5
on a du jeu quoi que vous prendrez 5 ou
d'un me 3 dame 3 ça fait un pion non
faut pas en V5 ça a l'air d'être le coup
ou à 4 peut-être pour faire puis on
prend les 5 bon c'était une autre option
mais il faut prendre ça qu'on est obligé
de jouer KS c'est 5 je pense il faut
prendre un si c'est une trop grosse
menace quoi d'autre
[Musique]
clairement de 45 entre une 20
mais il y a quand même du jeu pour la
qualité alors vous me direz oui la jauge
tout ça certes mais c'est pas facile à
jouer avec cette dame un peu en jeu mais
comment on la prend et 5 vas-y et ouais
il envoie ça y est il envoie les pièces
à l'abordage obligé mais là ça fait deux
fois avec les Noirs dans l'ouverture où
il est complètement complètement dans
les cordes mvl c'est trop
c'est trop contre ces joueurs là trop de
handicap qui est des 7 OK
peut-être un petit coup de tour des un
pour poser la question à se
c'est normal
on va voir ce qu'il va faire
ergazing je vous mets d'autres tours D1
ok c'est tout à fait logique
petit coup de F3 peut-être pour calmer
les ardeurs
du joueur français
parce que c'est vrai que le F4 est
embêtant c'est obligé de reculer sur une
case où on n'a pas envie d'aller sur une
diagonale on n'a pas envie d'aller alors
que F3 permet de reculer un F2
que va-t-il faire
que va-t-il faire à Jon
on sait pas
je me change dans les lunettes de Maxime
là on va se changer de position quand
même
et il joue F4 oulala F4 c'est vraiment
un coup très très agressif mais il se
prend j'ai 5 à tempo
est-ce que on peut pas tout liquider
faut prendre 7 faut prendre des 7 puis
on prend 5 puis on prend 5 il va
regarder ce genre de choses hein mais
bon ça a l'air d'aller dame B6 mc8 et ça
a l'air d'aller pour les noirs
on va voir il le rattrape autant
attention parce que Maxime dans ce genre
de position ouh là là le cavalier le
cavalier qui arrive dame B6 mc8 on garde
les dames évidemment même moi je
garderai la dans cette position autant
vous dire que Maxime va les garder
même ces 8 qui a tout reprend des six
peut-être oh il a pas regardé les dames
alors ça c'est le choc il est peur de te
reprendre ici je suppose
c'est la catastrophe si on regarde pas
les dents dans cette position
c'est le désastre
c'est le désastre en qualité nette de
moins et en plus des pions faibles
et je me suis organisé en plus
pour quelle catastrophe
qu'elle est énorme poubelle
voilà là là
F3 allez menace F2 évidemment pour un
joueur du calibre des vues à tempo ce
genre de petites choses on attaque ici
c'est la défendable
ah là là je sais pas comment on peut
faire c'est limite à la limite de
l'abandon là Maxime qui est dans le dur
faut prendre à deux faut prendre des six
va arriver
très clairement
très clairement et ouais ouais ouais
ouais ouais ouais non ça va pas ouais
c'est complètement perdant au moins il a
ce petit espoir depuis une fois qu'il
perce le pion il peut abandonner
si le père on espère pas tourner 4 ok
pour faire tout le 4
c'est pas mal joué un tour F5 pour
chatouiller ce fou on sait jamais fouder
cette eh ouais on est prêt à tous les
échanges avec les Blancs là
quoi d'autre il faut bien protéger
espion et la tour était attaquée donc il
est pas vraiment le choix
ouais mais bon
et ouais c'est ça le problème c'est
qu'on peut jouer gentiment avec les
Blancs et c'est complètement gagnant
c'est qu'on n'a pas besoin de faire
grand-chose de particulier ici avec les
Blancs pour l'emporter
fini puis on prend il va reprendre ce
pion qui dangereux quand même hein on a
SKF 3 et on reprend G2 on voit pas ouais
il fait H5 quoi d'autre il va essayer
d'envoyer ses pions mais bon
dur d'y croire là
même avec tout le talent
tout le talent tactique de Maxime
machinagrave il y a quand c'est pas ma
position c'est pas dans la position
qu'est-ce que je vous dise
c'est ça qu'est-ce qui se passe sur vous
aussi pour ces 7 tout simplement je
suppose
et en plus le Roi peut être prêt à
partir maintenant pour ces 7 va être
joué des cinq on va faire moi j'ai trois
gentiment et il y a des matchs du
couloir maintenant la tour qui peut
descendre à 8
et réfléchir June ah non il prend parce
que sur fulpron il a tout à 8
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
on sait plus là il va tomber non il est
pas tombé il fait échec mais bon et
cavalier 5 mais maintenant faut 6 il
faut prendre et à Tours 8 maths abandon
de Maxime La Grave et victoire une fois
de plus archi impressionnante
de son adversaire qui a déroulé après
l'ouverture une fois de plus non mais
contre Maxime oui et on a pragonie alors
peut-être la première défaite de visite
on sait pas
on sait pas contre visite qui nous a
habitué
à faire des parties les plus longues de
la ronde et on voit vite la Casson roi
qui est très active c'est complètement
gagnant
et seront rangés de ouais mais qui est
loin on peut le dominer comme ça si on a
envie qu'il y ait des deux et le roi ne
revient plus jamais c'est le réflexe
menace cavalier 4 et ensuite 3 C4 et qui
prend C3 et qu'elle prend à 4 et c'est
terminé
Maxime qu'est-ce qui se passe
il a joué roi F1
sur KD2 le coup jouet est de roi F1 il
se marre Prague il a fait un coup
illégal et oui ça arrive ça arrive même
à ses meilleurs joueurs du monde donc on
a maintenant la règle sur en tout cas
c'est
coup illégal ne perd pas la partie bon
de toute façon il est tellement foutu
que
illégal ne perd pas la partie mais
pour abandonner franchement
il rigole bon il sourit
ça le fait rire parce que effectivement
il faut Henri ou en pleurer tu as pas le
choix
qui est le second dent de ml
c'est Laurent Blanc
incroyable
reconverti au foot aux échecs
et abandon de Prague
ouais marrant
ça les fait rire c'est le plus important
qu'est-ce qui se passe est-ce qu'il y a
des parties et il reste pas de partie
donc on va faire un petit point un petit
point classement
en nouvelle défaite de mvl qui est
vraiment pas à son top aujourd'hui et
non j'ai pas du tout
j'ai pas du tout mis il est bon résultat
je le fais tout de suite
des fêtes de mvl Google
qui continue sa son beau tournoi gamer
avec les noirs et à douceur alors
quel est le classement ça se resserre en
tête de classement avec 5 et demi sur 7
pour Prague
5 sur 7 pour visiter gretchu donc c'est
très serré 4 et demi pour ergamesi qui
est un embuscade qui vient de battre
Maxime avec Christina agukh 50% avec 3
et demi gamer Abdou satorov qui est pas
en grande forme de cette tournoi de
l'ennemi et simplement deux points pour
notre MVN national c'est un peu triste
mais bon ben on va on va voir on va voir
la prochaine on espère on espère de
points qu'est-ce que je vous dise
on espère être trois alors à la partie
d'avant maintenant on espère de et joue
avec Christina avec les Blancs ok ça
rappelle des bons souvenirs c'était la
ronduite du tournoi rapide ah oui en
fait il joue les mêmes les mêmes
appareils
on n'est pas la moitié du tournoi donc
on sait jamais on sait jamais s'il y a
une belle série là
de aujourd'hui et demain genre deux
victoires maintenant et 5 victoires
demain voilà ça peut ça remonte on
remonte vite attention
mais effectivement c'est quand même
c'est quand même assez mal parti
on va se mettre sur cette partie contre
la Krishna
et on va voir est-ce que c'est la bonne
ou pas et on voit les arbitres qui se
qui se pressent pour
faire
pour installer les nouveaux échiquiers
c'est quand même assez
il y a du rythme dans ce temps de Blitz
clairement tous les 20 minutes je me
rappelle au grand cheese tour c'était
tout des 30 minutes c'était vraiment
très long
là tout des 20 minutes le temps
d'attente est pas si long que ça c'est
ça qui a géré hein Blitz le plus dur à
gérer c'est les tons c'est les attentes
entre les rondes
c'est très très compliqué
mais on voit que ça se resserre en haut
du classement donc c'est pas mal quand
même
c'est pas mal pour nous que ça se
resserre ça veut dire ça permet ça donne
plus de chance à Maxime de revenir
on va trouver la cam de Maxime il aura
les blancs face à
ouais il pourrait faire 0 sur 18 ça
serait quand même moche après un si beau
tournoi rapide
donc on lui souhaite de faire mieux
évidemment
de toute façon il fait déjà mieux mais
on lui souhaite déjà de revenir ça va
pas le
ravir un bon après maintenant il va
encore jouer un système de Londres là
c'est dommage
c'est dommage tellement il est fort dans
son répertoire
et tellement il le connaît bien en bide
c'est parfait son répertoire parce qu'il
le connaît très bien il le joue tout le
temps et les joueurs ont pas le temps de
se préparer
donc c'est quand même c'est triple bingo
là il essaye de il tente des choses à
droite à gauche mais ça prend pas trop
il a pas l'habitude de jouer c'est
ces ouvertures là pourquoi il a décidé
il a pris le parti de pas jouer sans
répertoire mais c'est vrai qu'en Blitz
c'est toujours toujours délicat de
montrer des choses et d'habitude c'est
ce qui fait notamment pour les
champignons de Bleach il joue toujours
son
répertoire
mais en l'occurrence ici il a pris le
parti de pas le faire
ce qui est un peu dommage effectivement
quel est l'intérêt nous demande ça se
pour une nouvelle de varier sur
répertoire sur un tournevis c'est
maintenant moi je vois pas trop mais
[Musique]
parce que toute façon ce répertoire est
tellement tout le monde le connaît son
répertoire donc il montre pas grand
chose quand il joue ses ouvertures il a
tellement le feeling pour ses ouvertures
que c'est un peu dommage
mais il veut peut-être tenter d'autres
choses c'est ça le truc aussi peut-être
que demain il va il va réajuster le tir
mais voir en blitz peut-être des choses
qui peuvent marcher peut-être qu'il a
fait partie d'entraînement où ça
marchait bien
je n'en sais rien
c'est un test et on voit qu'il est
autant on voit le temps qui prend à la
pendule c'est ça qui est temps à chaque
fois
prochaine rentre dans deux minutes
et demain on prend les mêmes et on
recommence
à partir de 10h15
je vais regarder si le chaud est bien
programmé
10h15 les parties
je crois que le show j'avais regardé
tout à l'heure
vous avez
ce soir
à lireza contre
André King à suivre sur cette même
chaîne
à partir de 18h45 très très beau match
du speed chess champion chip qui a lieu
en ce moment sur cheesecom le jeune
prince
Ali resa qui je vous racontera et King
qui fera figure de grands favoris
évidemment 18h45 sur chaise comme
commenté en français
et
alors c'est quelle heure en attente 9
septembre 11h15 non c'est faux c'est
faux ce qu'il y a sur Youtube j'ai
envoyé un petit message
à Nathan
notre ami Nathan
est-ce qu'il est là maintenant j'ai un
bug avec mon
téléphone ouais dans Demain c'est 10h30
mettre un petit message est-ce qu'on a
les tableaux du résultat actuel le
tableau non mais on a le classement
voilà vous pouvez regarder le classement
et
voilà le classement donc Prague
ouais demain c'est 10h30 le nouveau est
mis au commentaire je crois pas je crois
je crois que j'ai vu que c'était Kevin
bordi aux commentaires
il me semble il me semble que c'est
Kévin qui commentera le match d'Ali resa
ce soir
donc on rappelle la Formule 1 de ce
speechage Championship 1h30 de 5 + 1h de
3 + 1 et une demi-heure de un plus un
ça va être sympa ça va être très très
sympa à suivre évidemment
on espère que
Cali Raisa lui met une pâtée
voilà c'est tout ce qu'on espère
allez allez
Maxime pardon avec faut mettre une bulle
à Cristina c'est ça que je voulais dire
on va encourager les adversaires de
Maxime pour voir si ça marche ou pas
on indique au joueur de s'installer et
on voit Maxime va chez La Grave qui
s'installe
et là on est bien pour jouer contre à
Krishna on aura pas de 4 pour
aujourd'hui on aura un des quatre une
fois de plus j'ai l'impression
à 18h45 ça dure ça dure 3 heures je
crois
oui donc un peu plus de 3 heures
et on voit Maxime qui sert la mer avec
Christina et que ça qui fait un tour de
[__] c'est tout à fait raisonnable
rapide il avait pris l'eau il a fini
dernier je crois mais là il est quand
même
il est quand même raisonnable
allez
on va se mettre comme ça
pour voir notre Maxime national si peut
nous mettre un point là
avant qu'on un ou deux points là avant
qu'on se quitte pour demain
pour espérer un meilleur jour et une
remontée c'est ça en fait
duel entre agneau roi
ouais peut-être ça peut-être que c'est
ça est-ce que un gros malus pour essayer
une chanson aux autres il a baillé c'est
bon signe d'accord
non je crois pas c'est pas le style de
Maxime de fêter la victoire quand on est
pas terminé
même si tu auras de partir rapide et
déjà gagné ça c'est dans le ça c'est
fait mais effectivement il est quand
même il est quand même sérieux jusqu'au
bout il adore le Blitz
il joue ses quatre ok un petit
changement et on va voir peut-être une
structure Carlsbad
et bien oui
et un fougez 5 fois 7 ah il va jouer le
truc avec fougères je suppose
alors il jouait avec tout re 8 ok
pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas et cavalier F3 maintenant
ok on peut normalement jouer plus souple
avec cavalier 2 mais on peut aussi
décider de faire cavalier F3
tout à fait normal
ok ok ça va
ça va mais c'est plus facile avec les
Blancs improvise c'est toujours pareil
que les Noirs
directement et je vais changer les
pendules évidemment vu que ça change à
chaque fois
donc c'est quand même plus simple assez
une structure assez solide joue un petit
coup de fouet 4 certainement pour
surprendre à quelqu'un mais là c'est
vrai que ça donne ces 5 à un coup
et c'est normalement ok pour les Noirs
ce genre de structure qui est ici va
arriver mais ça va c'est complètement
jouable une structure de pion isolé tout
à fait standard
un bon développement pour les Noirs mais
rien de rien de grave qui est B5 menace
à fourchette et surtout replace le
cavalier pour aller en D4 mais que tout
recettes je suppose mais tout recettes
pour C1
voici un peu un peu désagréable pour les
Noirs faut répondre à des questions
c'est la partie tour de cette tour c'est
on rappelle je vois streamlabs qui nous
dit abonnez-vous oui à notre chaîne
YouTube pour soutenir la production du
contenu sur les échecs
nous recommençons à produire des vidéos
et des shorts sur la chaîne en plus des
live et nous vous êtes votre soutien
pour cela abonnez-vous likez les vidéos
et comme ça vous n'aurez rien de ce qui
se passe dans le monde des échecs
abonnez-vous aux réseaux sociaux aussi
n'hésitez plus
ça coûte rien et ça nous soutient et ça
vous informe
H3 jouer pour empêcher un éventuel
fujectre vous aussi stocker ça c'est un
peu c'est pas un coup ambitieux faut
aussi mais bon il sort ses pièces on va
pas le pas lui en vouloir créer des
quatre et on est pas mal on est pas mal
avec les Blancs là petit plus petit plus
pour les blancs ouverture réussie
non c'est plus à vendre acheter un
premium c'est fini
tonus prono c'est fini ce temps là on en
vend plus trop tard
trop tard pour le Premium vous avez du
retard c'est le Premium cheesecom ça par
contre ça coûte de l'argent mais ça
offre plein de
plein de services
mais ça vous permet aussi de soutenir la
cause
et les puzzle illimité l'analyse qui est
meilleure tout un tas de trucs je sais
pas exactement il y a aussi des vidéos
en français des vidéos en anglais la 6
allez-y
on y va
on peut plus Mrs 67 comment on fait pour
acheter les vidéos d'ouverture sur 24 on
ne peut plus c'est trop tard c'est raté
ça n'a pas été pareil allez vas-y allez
Maxime il calcule bon il l'a vu il l'a
vu il a raté à Christina oh là il se
prend des tactiques ça fait deux jours
qu'il se prend les tactiques par mvl
avec Christina avec sa tentative de
combinière qui n'a pas du tout marché ce
dame bien raté pour ceux qui étaient là
il faut prendre aussi jouer cavalier 4
il appelait impressionné mais il revient
F4 qu'est-ce qui se passe sur kid2 il y
a de la H5 sur le cahier des deux
menaces de H7
j'ai 6 vas-y que je t'envoie faut
prendre G6 et oui et il joue il joue au
plus malin contre mvl en niveau tactique
c'est pas un truc qui se termine bien en
général j'ai 6 fous prends G6 et
regarder moi ça faut prendre puis on
prend dame prend ton G7 badaboum venez
me prendre j'ai fait trois aussi qui
gagne aussi mais ça c'est pas mal là on
a quand même pris pas mal de matériel on
est complètement gagnant d'un match qui
revient à Krishna
mais c'est pas terrible du tout cette
histoire
et il est mal au temps il faut prendre
le capture prend le 4 il nous fait une
Master Class la communauté de faire mais
vous voyez quand l'ouverture se passe
bien c'est quand même une autre
mayonnaise c'est pas le même mvl qu'on
voit qui prend aussi et on va jouer un
petit coup de tour dehors là eh oui la
tour au centre bien joué Maxime dame 7
on est dans un clouage c'est l'enfer
dame 8 on perd une pièce il est
complètement foutu avec Krishna
me cette même dame c'est 5 doit gagner
facile n'importe quel couvre et mon
premier réflexe et échanger dame il y a
mieux que ça c'est sûr c'est sûr qu'il y
a mieux que ça mais c'est suffisant
même si vous pensez cette gagne
et oui c'est trop tard
c'est trop tard Mr chess
et oui
67 ça serait pas le Bas-Rhin ça
alors non je raconte c'est le Haut-Rhin
non je sais pas quel département
alors et je vois final de tour qui est
gagnant techniquement parce qu'on a trop
de faiblesses on a un peu moins et des
faiblesses une faiblesse ici une
faiblesse ici une faiblesse ici ça ne va
pas vas-y que je te montre le roi
et que je t'encaisse le pion peut-être
tour des 6 pour couper d'abord petit
geste technique
le rein du milieu
je sais pas mais 77 ça me dit quelque
chose c'est le Barin et oui Florent
herbe tu as vu je m'y connais on
département de club et Roger trois va
arriver
et oui on salue nos amis de Bischwiller
évidemment
j'ai trois ouais quatre puis en plus et
dernière
qui sont les champions de France en fin
c'est mérité
c'est complètement mérité
on encaisse ici hyper encore un pion
autour des 7 tours
mais il veut s'activer un petit peu il a
compris que sur le sur la durée il était
foutu toute façon
il prend même pas le pion j'ai en mode
découpé découpé tu ne bouges plus
j'amène mon roi je fais ce que je veux
avec toi je joue j'ai trois d'abord et
ensuite il va encaisser le pion vous
inquiétez pas pour lui
ouais il peut abandonner il se
s'appelle ça s'appelle une pâtée
allez vas-y prends le pion j'adore
prends moi ce pion quand même allez
allez Maxime
la préfecture du Bas-Rhin j'ai 33 je
t'en pose des questions moi
c'est dans le haut Strasbourg c'est pas
loin à Strasbourg je sais Strasbourg
facile c'est facile de Strasbourg
et oui c'est à côté je sais que c'est à
coté
ah et maintenant qu'est-ce qu'il va
faire il va pousser jusque là et
normalement on pousse pas si on veut
ramener le roi parce que on se prend à
cause des échecs ah il fait au hk3g5 qui
vont casser les pions évidemment
évidemment il aura 30 ans de plus ça va
être un abandon chère avec les chiens on
va aller voir une autre partie
masterclass
de mvl et non il défend son pion ok mais
il va être zigzang
les exemples et oui il a pas de bon coup
s'il reste sur cette colonne on fait ça
et dames si ça va et bien on prend le
pion terminé
masterclass bravo Maxime ça fait plaisir
allez on va voir une autre partie
rapidement
peut-être un peu de glitchouc ou un peu
de
gagnant visite a gagné un petit peu de
Prague Prague est foutu contre bouquet
je suppose oui ça perd une pièce on va
aller voir notre ami Sacha gritchouk si
on le trouve si on le trouve on le met
en direct il est là il est là Sacha et
on va update évidemment le score de
Maxime machinagrave qui pourrait s'y
mettait un dernier point les quatre sur
9 ça serait ça serait évidemment
beaucoup moins qu'espérer mais ça sera
encore jouable pour demain ça ferait
plaisir parce qu'on sait qu'il peut les
faire ces séries de victoire on a une
finale de dingue Michael Jon plus ça
peut durer longtemps
ça peut durer longtemps
ça peut durer jusqu'à demain cette
histoire
il est pas si mal finalement oui il est
pas si bien non plus hein
c'est ça
pseudo pseudonyme la
le gentleman en tout cas à haut niveau
moi je vous parle de citron à fermer en
général c'est celui qui perd
qui engage à conversation si la nana
envie
c'est comme ça que ça se passe
ce que j'ai pu remarquer ce que j'ai
fait
voilà c'est en général si c'est nul
évidemment c'est ouvert en général les
joueurs se parlent mais si ça perd d'un
des deux côtés c'est celui qui perd qui
a conversation
qui peut une sorte de forme de politesse
sans être évidemment
une règle écrite
il fait chaud il fait chaud ça c'est
vrai
il fait chaud mais notre ami du BTP a
décidé de faire une pause entre midi et
deux c'est mérité c'est parce que c'est
dur franchement
je le
avec cette chaleur j'ai envie pas du
tout
et puis surtout ça deadline des JO et
oui on construit des on construit des
stades
il a bien bossé cette semaine aussi oui
c'est vrai c'est vendredi bon il peut
finir plus tôt
on lui en voudra pas
il y a pas été rabossé ce weekend moi je
vous le dis
on se prend une lettre
alors comment on fait il faut se garer
spion ça peut durer des heures
évidemment c'est nul d'un point de vue
objectif mais alors ça reste du Blitz
comme vous le savez et ça peut être
évident le rêve des Noirs c'est
d'arriver à échanger ce pion contre ce
pion c'est ça l'objectif
tant qu'il reste ses pions sur
l'échiquier c'est une défense vraiment
pas facile
et il revient et Abdou Saltov en fait de
même
donc il a pris le pion finalement
il va jouer ce 3 contre 2
mais 3 contre 2 même 4 contre 3h
tout à fait tout à fait le Stade
olympique la piscine olympique qui est
en train d'être construite dans le 11e
incroyable
alors
ouais mais bon là c'est trop dur c'est
trop facile à défendre pour les Noirs le
problème c'est que si on se crée un pion
passé ça va être un pion h
et le pion à chaque le roi sur ce côté
c'est quand même complètement nul
aucune chance
aucune chance pour Sacha qui joue bon
pourquoi pas
il voit si si Abdou on en est déjà au
centième coup on va pas faire une gaffe
et ce qui nous met en retard non la
prochaine partie dans 8 minutes
ça peut durer deux trois minutes encore
cette histoire ah j'ai 4 ouais bon ça
c'est un aveu
mais toute façon quoi d'autre quoi
d'autre c'était obligé de faire ça il y
a tellement aucune chance de gagner
cette partie Adam 4 ok mais évidemment
qui fera pas ça et maintenant c'est
parti pour les échecs
mais bon il tente sa chance de chou
qu'il a bien il a bien raison
et ouais le problème c'est quand même
les finales de pions sont nuls
il est pas inquiet roi G8 c'est facile
c'est trop facile à défendre
ouh là dame j'ai 5 attention
il a l'opposition qu'est-ce que je
raconte
est nul
nul entre les deux joueurs
on va aller voir on va aller voir les
résultats de cette ronde avec
grichu qui vient de faire nul contre
gamer
Prague donc ça va faire un resserrement
en tête et on va découvrir
combien on a de retard Raja bof qui va
regayy ça c'est très bon pour nous que
les derniers battent les premiers parce
que ça fait trois points de retard sur
vidite alors effectivement c'est
beaucoup et peu à la fois deux points de
retard sur Prague et grid mais voilà
podium peut être envisagé que un point
et demi entre guillemets sur Erika ici
et Google
A3
gamer 2 et demi et Raja BOV 2 qui marque
sa première victoire il y a 18 rondes on
est à la ronde 8 aujourd'hui là on va
jouer la dernière ronde
du
[Musique]
on va jouer la dernière onde du Bleach
et on va regarder contre qui joue il va
jouer à jabov et oui c'est les mêmes
appareils manquant rapide Raja bof avec
les Noirs espérons encore jobslagène
quand même Raja bof mvl Prague et
gamer goûte
à Krishna gritchouk ouais tout est
encore faisable c'est que clairement et
la prochaine partie et dernière partie
de la journée dans 6 minutes
donc il va falloir qu'il fasse quelque
chose dans cette partie
on va évidemment rester sur
Maxime
et on va regarder
sa dernière partie de Blitz pour la
journée en tout cas
et Maxime va chez Lagrave
qui a les noirs
qui vont gentiment s'installer il est
quelle heure en Inde en 16 Google
ça non je pense qu'il y a 2h30 de plus
3h30
2h30 ou 3h30 + 3,30 ouais merci
donc 3 30 c'est 17h30 oui c'est ça selon
mes souvenirs c'était 3 30 et c'est
logique pour nous ça commence à à 11h30
donc pour eux c'est 15h et demain il
reprendront à 14h certainement avec une
remise des prix
qui suivra
on va voir
Maxime est-ce qu'il s'installe on va
essayer de le trouver notre ami
[Musique]
notre ami mvl
et là
mais c'est bien le sol pour l'instant en
tout cas
4h30 en hiver et oui quand on change
d'heure
oui oui assez peu de dégageoires c'est
vrai
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai
on y était je me rappelle que c'était
pas énorme ça m'avait surpris au moment
où j'étais allé jouer aux jeux
olympiques l'année dernière là-bas à
Chennai
et donc c'était assez peu je me souviens
plus si c'était ben non c'était en août
donc ça devait être 3h30 aussi et donc
effectivement c'est vrai quand on se dit
on va en Inde on a l'impression d'aller
au bout du monde
pour nous évidemment on n'a pas sûr que
c'est loin quoi et on se dit qu'il va y
avoir plus de décalage
et bien non
c'est la bonne surprise
début de la suivante dans 3 minutes
pendant que le camion passe alors
est-ce que Maxime est là
ça j'ai l'impression que c'est Raja bof
ah oui
parce qu'on voit les joueurs qui sont en
t-shirt ou en chemise ouverte
chemise ouverte
la suite
et donc
voilà normalement on a une tenue un peu
plus
[Musique]
habillé mais là bon s'il fait ça il fait
chaud il fait chaud
alors Maxime
ah ouais tes mots on espère qu'il va pas
il va pas jouer sur d'oranger on le
connaît quand il veut être solide il est
très dur à battre
bon je sais pas franchement bravo
bravo bravo
tout à fait
politique animale
Pro vous avez vu quelques problèmes
gastro-digestif dans l'équipe non
honnêtement
certains oui certains plus que d'autres
certains rien du tout je crois
moi c'était très largement supportable
honnêtement ça allait quoi un petit peu
c'était pas comme à la maison vous voyez
ce que je veux dire mais c'était pas non
plus à me mettre mal donc ça allait quoi
et effectivement il nous servait on est
quand même dans les hôtels
on était bien on était bien sûr
et donc ouais la nourriture était quand
même
adaptée aux Européens
donc ça allait
rien de
en tout cas pour moi certains ont
[Musique]
en morflé plus que les autres c'est ça
c'est la nature
alors qu'est-ce qu'on va avoir chez
Maxime
on ne sait pas je me suis aux escaliers
allez c'est parti
en haut
et on a et réfléchi en premier coup ça
c'est marrant c'est un truc qu'on ne
fait pas anglais il va faire comme hier
ok bébé 7 et il fait le 3 ok petite
surprise
3 vous faut 7 comme dans un candidat
et B3 il va jouer fou B2 et fou D3 ok ça
c'est une position pour jouer clairement
donc ça c'est la première bonne nouvelle
la première bonne nouvelle c'est que tes
mots est disposé à essayer de gagner
face à Maxime Vacher la grave
et ça ça nous arrange on se met tout au
bout de la salle
pour pas gêner la vue de Maxime
et sur B6 il prend des 5 ouais c'est
logique comme ça
le fou Soto
le fou buttera sur son propre pion
va faire foudre ensuite bon c'est à peu
près tout est complètement normal ici
il se passe pas grand chose
ah les timer désolé
les timer comme on dit les pendules
désolé
gros à chaque fois et on voit encore une
fois de plus 20 30 secondes une position
pas si facile à jouer on voit qu'il a
pas l'habitude
tours c'est on va faire fout des 6 je
suppose
fais tourner
on aime déjà pas j'aime pas trop sa
position ça va c'est raisonnable on va
pas on va pas pleurer
c'est
raisonnable pour les noirs sans être
folichon
là parfois on échange ce foot de casse
blanche pour affaiblir le pion en dessin
que potentiellement il fait tourner un
abord qui est très très logique
j'ai l'impression qu'il va se le prendre
quand même x 6 un jour ou l'autre et il
se le prend
c'est archi thématique
ce coup de fouassie
et on voit qu'il aime bien sa position
déjà Raja bof il a bien raison
il est là
j'aime pas sa pause
de terminer par une défaite
et lui non plus il aime pas il réfléchit
40 secondes de moins déjà
et ouais bien obligé de prendre et je
vais tourner 5 on fait pardon c'est 5 on
fait cavalier prend
et
ça va plus ou moins
sur ton H2 la petite combinette
habituelle
des quatre cavaliers F5 ou alors j'ai
trois rois G2
on peut améliorer sa position à volonté
il réfléchir à jabof on a un bon pion
isolé
pour les blancs
F6 donc c'était pas forcément terrible
H3 cool logique
qui ne menace pas de prendre mais bon
qui fait une petite case
j'aurais plutôt joué G3 ici
bon après c'est une question de goût
et
est-ce que cahier des quatre va arriver
j'aime pas trop comment il a fait H3
laisse toujours cadeau 5 et vous voyez
on va chatouiller par là il y a quelque
chose à quoi on doit penser ah j'ai
trois me semble mieux
14h15 ça reprend de plus belle
oh là là
notre ami qui a fait une petite pause
mais il revient
soit pour faire des deux pour provoquer
un affaiblissement chez les Noirs
bienvenue mais ça a mis du temps et
Maxime qui est bien revenu autant sur
dame on va faire il va faire de la fuite
je le connais par cœur
pourquoi pas F6 c'est moche quand même
une sorte de
proposition de nulle silencieuse mais
non il le fait pas il fait dame C3 il
garde la pression sur cette grande
diagonale
d'un B7 pour s'organiser et récupérer la
colonne C
et maintenant comment on fait
Dame des 4 ok
il avait tout vu Maxime
une vingt contre une 5
et ça revient Maxime qui serait d'accord
pour une nul vu que sa position est
quand même pas terrible
approximatif il voulait faire la MC3
ensuite il a fait des deux il joue la
gagne évidemment Raja bof il a besoin de
points on l'a connu moins belliqueux
mais là il a deux sur 8 il a deux survie
donc ça c'est notre chance c'est pas mal
ça peut être pas mal pour nous ça
ça peut ça peut être un point on aura
déjà bof qui prend trop de risques il
est pas habitué
mais il est bien quand même dame
Descartes que j'ai quatre peut arriver
et tours c'est vite et qu'est-ce qui se
passe sur kg 4 je n'en sais rien j'ai
pas la refais il veut du contre je parle
il veut peut-être prendre
prendre d'abord et du contre je parle
dans Dame des trois il laisse rien il y
a rien à jouer
dame prend n'est pas possible faut des
hyper le fil dans la BOF il la joue pas
bien ce pur isolé il avait un beau pur
isolé maintenant c'est en train de son
avantage est en train de diminuer et F3
à être obligé de jouer un coup comme F3
ça fait pas plaisir
et c'est 5 cavaliers
certainement
est-ce que cavalier aussi c'est le
prochain coup oui
et ça joue la gagne maintenant à mon
avis du côté français
parce qu'elle est très chaude cette
position c'est une position à trois
résultats attention ce pion en E3 qui
est un peu faible comment on fait il
fait A4 c'est pas mal ça j'aime bien
mais là ça trois
Scipion prend puis on prend et cette
dame se réveille intéressant
et 33 secondes pour adjabov va falloir
accélérer contre 39 c'est là où Maxime
est le meilleur
il a réussi à tourner tout ça
il est là
ouh là
comment il fait à
complètement frisé regardez 8 secondes
il bouge plus il bouge plus
il bouge plus
de temps et ouais non là ça y est Maxime
qui a pris le dessus là clairement
et ça continue ça continue à jouer
rapidement du côté de Maxime il faut
cette moyenne de fois F6 on peut jamais
prendre ce pion il y a toujours ces deux
autour c'est un il fait F4 pour faire
cavalier F3 mais il est en mode panique
il a un mode panique Raja bof complet et
attention avec si peu de temps contre
Maxime ce sont normalement des choses
qui ne pardonnent pas
et ça y est l'objectif en mieux pour ces
trois va arriver dame B6 va arriver il a
plein de faiblesses
on s'organise skyprien F4 aussi et là oh
là là d'un point 3 sur échec et qui
avait les profs 4 va être joué ou d'un
prime 4 ou tout est bon d'après très
bien
peut-être pour éviter tout contre jeu
peut-être deux pour organiser son propre
jeu attention il y a pas d'échec il y a
pas d'échec ici c'est contrôler
cavaliers 5
Raja bof qui revient un petit peu
attention au pion quand même si on
laisse travailler comme Maxime il prend
un moment il a pris comme prévu
et un petit coup de un petit coup de
finale là attention au pion attention au
pion on peut pas faire n'importe quoi
et c'est complètement gagnant avec ces
deux pions de plus pour Maxime il suffit
de protéger F7 gentiment
même peut-être dame j'ai trois à la
contre-attaque il protège et il veut
pousser ouais c'est le coup du pro ça
ouh là il a craqué complètement à deux
qui prend à deux il perd une pièce
n'importe quoi
abondons de Temora jabot français et
d'autres parties en cours mais le
Français qui termine très très bien
ce tournoi
enfin la journée et la journée pas là
c'est pas le tournoi
et on voit aller vite qui nous fait
comme d'habitude dernier a terminé
comme d'hab
et ouais ça joue ça joue encore chez
visitant à tourner chez
bon côté c'est gagnant apparemment pour
et on va update le score de Maxime
agrafe qui a maintenant 4 sur 9 ok c'est
pas ce qu'on espérait mais à zéro sur
trois on prenait le 4 sur 9
quand même fait 4 sur 5 sur les 5 sur
les 5 dernières donc c'est quand même
très très raisonnable comme score de fin
de journée
non il a fait 4 sur 6 bon
et à ce pion e qui devrait décider la
partie
mais il fait ça
mais c'est pas grave
est-ce qu'il prend le fou ou pas non il
protège il en veut plus
Abdou ça il veut faire roisser cette 3D
oh là là on sait pas ce qu'il veut faire
et on voit les deux joueurs qui jouent
extrêmement vite et si il va faire dame
c'est fini
il fait des mois prochain coup à
un petit peu dans ce tournoi
et dame victoire contre le leader et
donc ça voudrait dire
et non ça voudrait dire que Maxime a
deux points et demi de retard
je pensais deux points simplement sur
visiter effectivement mais il a deux
points et demi de Prague qui est fait un
début de journée très très
impressionnant au programme de si c'est
mission neuve très beau score quand même
vite chouk avec 6
et
avec 4 et demi
mvl Abdou Sator
[Musique]
gamer 3 et demi et Raja BOV 2 bon bon il
a repris des places effectivement et
surtout il est pas si loin de la tête de
trois victoires demain pour commencer et
il est dans le il est dans le mix comme
on dit
on va voir demain ça sera les mêmes
appareils évidemment mais en tout cas
Maxime machinagrave après sa performance
extraordinaire
d'hier dans le rapide 7 sur 9 un peu
plus dans le dur 4 sur 9 simplement dans
le Blitz mais une bonne fin de journée
et tous les espoirs reste permis avec 9
parties à jouer de main donc il peut se
passer énormément
de choses demain c'est 10h30 même
endroit
même joueur même commentateur
je vous remercie infiniment
de nous avoir suivi et je vous donne
rendez-vous donc dès demain 10h30 pour
cette deuxième journée de Blitz et
dernier jour du stata style chassisia la
portion
Blitz une excellente journée à tout le
monde et à demain ciao ciao
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechestre
ou les title Tuss
day.com/aventure tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroulent en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires